Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt mein name ist tim und.
Es ist der neunzehnte mai zwanzig zwanzig.
Man müsste vielleicht sagen so und so viel tage nach corona aber wer weiß schon wann das angefangen hat hier ist corona weekly ich begrüße pavel hallo papa.
Tag siebenundachtzig nach meiner zeitrechnung die beginnt halt an der stelle wo die zahlen.
Langsam konsistent werden und man mit rechnen kann am samstag den zweiundzwanzigsten zwoten.
Da fing alles an sozusagen.
In deutschland.
Das heißt dann okay das heißt wir haben jetzt auch fast oder so gut wie drei monate hinter uns mit dieser ganzen situation okay.
Zeit mal wieder zu resümieren ja.
Heute wird es vielleicht nicht ganz so lang aber wer weiß das schon so ganz genau.
Wir haben wieder viele kommentare von euch bekommen vielen dank dazu bevor ich es auch wieder vergesse auf vielen dank speziell an die leute die jetzt pavel da auch konkretes feedback gegeben haben bezüglich.
Fehlern der risiko tabelle da werden wir heute auf jeden fall auch noch mal einiges zu berichten haben,
ja aber ich denke wir können heute mal direkt mit den aktuellen zahlen aus deutschland
anfangen später sage ich nochmal ein bisschen was zu dieser ganzen apps situation.
Ja wie sieht's denn aus pavel werden wir alle sterben.
Ja nein es sieht eigentlich ganz okay aus also der berühmte wert beziehungsweise der neue berühmte.
Über sieben tage geglättete erwehrt liegt jetzt so bei null komma
acht drei also um um die null komma acht um je nachdem wie man die sieben tage glättung durchführt weil da gibt's auch nochmal verschiedene varianten.
Deine deine glättung ist das jetzt sozusagen.
Die unterscheidet sich jetzt also ist interessante ist dass es noch mal ein anderes interpretationen erfahren nimmt ich nehme halt
die mehrwerte der letzten sieben tage und bilde darüber den mittelwert sie bilden dann wiederum
den ersten mittelwert über die
fallzahlen von sieben tagen und bilden dann den erwerb auf basis sagen darf der vorher interpretierte daten und das führt zu einer leicht.
Anderen kurve aber im wesentlichen fast die gleichen ergebnisse aber sozusagen die glättung ist noch glatter.
Okay ist jetzt das eine besser als das andere.
Also sagen meins zeigt ein bisschen früher an wenn's hoch geht also,
und schlägt ein bisschen mehr aus als es aber nicht nichts wesentliches also unterschied ist denn jetzt gerade so ich
liege bei halt null komma acht drei und
glättung null komma acht null ging allerdings rechnet es nicht auf den normalen meldedaten sondern auf ihren cast daten insofern ist es nicht ganz vergleichbar aber ja
null komma acht ist das ding und wir hatten in der letzten woche so einen kleinen anstieg
selbst geglättet so auf fast eins bei glättung null komma neun fünf ja jedenfalls gab es einen anstieg.
Leichten und da war es unklar würde es jetzt vielleicht noch weiter über eins gehen aber nein der geglättete wert ist die ganze zeit unter eins geblieben und.
Ursache dafür gehe ich mal sehr stark davon aus für diesen anstieg von wenn man null komma sieben,
vor zwei wochen auf diese null komma neun kam daher dass ja die regeln für die tests geändert wurden und
das führte dazu dass halt einfach mehr tests durchgeführt werden und werden wir testet kriegt halt auch
mehr positive fälle und da die.
Zahlen also da dieses hatten wir beim letzten mal schon angesprochen da dieses eben nicht mit der zahl der tests auch normiert wird
kriegst du wenn sich die zahl der tests verändert steigt oder fällt halt auch das kurzfristig das
pegelt sich dann zwar wieder ein und das ist das glaube ich was wir jetzt gerade sehen morgen gibt's ja die neuen
test zahlen und so meine vermutung ist dass die tests nicht weiter hoch gegangen sind sondern
ich hoffe gleich geblieben sind wenn sie jetzt sogar gefallen sind dann werden wir jetzt wieder einen übertriebenen abfall von ersehen der.
Ganz den tatsachen entspricht aber es pendelt sich dann auch irgendwann ein aber insgesamt.
Kann man sagen gehen die zahlen zurück obwohl mehr getestet wurde so das kann man einfach festhalten das heißt
in der summe sieht es in deutschland gut aus so aber wenn man jetzt mal genauer hinguckt
wie sich das denn in der region unterscheidet kann man sagen wir haben ungefähr in der hälfte der landkreise,
sinkende zahlen und in einem viertel der landkreise aber steigende zahlen so und das ist natürlich nicht schön so das verbleibende viertel
da steigt oder sind wieder und das ist natürlich ein problem wenn
es gegen den gibt nach wie vor wo sich die infektion verbreiten wo sie sich ausbreiten heißt das es ist nicht unter kontrolle.
Das kann man halt festhalten trotz sinkender zahlen gibt's halt brandherde und,
da hatten wir ja auch jetzt geht ja jetzt durch die presse
sind dann häufig spezial situationen sich diese arbeiterwohnort heime oder auch gerade
dann gehört hat gesundheitspersonal ist jetzt wohl besonders stark betroffen was vielleicht daran liegt dass jetzt gesundheitspersonal besonders viel getestet wird so dann wundert es natürlich auch nicht
sagen durch die regeländerungen
jetzt sagen gesamte krankenhaus oder pflegeheimbewohnern schaften oder pflegeheime durchgetestet werden was vorher nicht der fall war dann findet man da natürlich jetzt
auch mehr fälle sowas jetzt nicht heißen muss dass sie nicht vor zwei wochen genauso betroffen waren sie wollen halt nur nicht getestet
so dass vielleicht auch als hintergrund zu den meldungen immer jetzt hört oh gott plötzlich so hohe zahlen bei krankenhaus- und pflegepersonal
das liegt sehr wahrscheinlich daran dass sie jetzt getestet werden und vorher nicht in der form.
Da wir jetzt in dieser phase sind so heute fünfhundert neue infizierte.
Auf ganz deutschland verteilt das ist dann wenn wir vierhundert landkreise haben ist es eigentlich im schnitt so anderthalb pro landkreis so das ist,
wenn das jetzt gleichmäßig verteilt wäre sagt wär super aber dem.
Halt nicht so und dank jetzt dieses corona risk ranking tools kann man jetzt halt auch sehr schön gucken dem neuen feature platzierungsziel veränderungen.
So sieht man dass die landkreise die weit oben sind auch weit oben bleiben also die
den top ten passiert da gerade nicht so richtig viel und so sieht's halt aus,
und größten bewegung beim ranking gibt's halt in meinem unten drittel weil da
genügend halt so ein paar wenige fälle um dich nach oben zu katapultieren aber ja oben,
oben sieht die situation relativ stabil aus ab und zu gutes gibt es jetzt seit zwei tagen des des feature am ersten tag ist mir glaube ich wenn ich recht mich recht entsinne
war das glaube ich karlsruhe des nico
coburg war's glaube ich was so weit hoch gehüpft ist jedenfalls ab und zu bricht irgendwo mal was aus und dann springt halt einen landkreis an die spitze und ansonsten
ist das feld eben verteilt ist sehr differenziert.
Inwiefern jetzt seine tabelle halt die realität widerspiegelt das ist halt auch eine frage der betrachtung
letztlich hängt es ja von dieser gewichtung ab und du hast ja in deiner tabellen- berechnung ebenso eine gewichtung von wir vergleichen die aktuelle woche,
der woche davor oder beziehungsweise den sieben tagen die letzten sieben tage und die sieben tage davor keine kalenderwoche hier geht es darum wirklich.
Jeden tag ändert sich das das heißt irgendein wert rutscht hinten in die vorwoche ganz hinten rutscht etwas komplett aus der betrachtung und wenn halt jetzt irgendwo wieder ein.
Ausbruch gemessen wird wir hatten jetzt den letzten tagen diese ganzen.
Meldungen von so schlachthöfen und solchen hotspots wo man noch nicht so ganz genau weiß haben die sich jetzt bei der arbeit angesteckt oder ist das eine eine eine auswirkung der
unterbringung weil diese arbeiter dann halt auch alle in solchen was kann ich mir das nennen soll unterkünften da untergebracht sind zusammen
einem zimmer schlafen et cetera ich habe da ein paar fotos gesehen das ist schon alles gruselig.
Also ich ich
verstehe diese unternehmer auch nicht so gerade in dieser situation so mein erster gedanke war als ich da hörte es kommen fremdarbeiterinnen so um in der landwirtschaft zu arbeiten dachte ich mir nah
super die ganzen hotels hinterher jetzt leer weil keine touristen da sind es wäre super gelegenheit den hoteliers,
irgendwie auch ein bisschen was zukommen zu lassen und dann
aber ja bisschen mehr wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel mehr auszugeben für die unterbringung aber dann wenigstens sicher zu sein dass die leute eigene zimmer haben und nicht zu,
oder sechzehn leuten teilweise,
einer bude hocken ich meine das ist doch das ist doch kompletter irrsinn und das das macht mich auch einfach rasend und und und wütend so diese ignoranz.
Ja wir alle müssen letztlich am ende mit ja verlängerten lok down einige leute vielleicht sogar mit ihrem leben dafür bezahlen ich meine was denken sich diese leute eigentlich
ich.
Teuer muss alles billig sein das fleisch so deutschland billig fleisch land.
Das ist ein zynischer kommentar aber trifft glaube ich die sache halbwegs denn.
Keine andere erklärung dafür dass die situation überhaupt so ist und das ist natürlich auch etwas wo man mal schauen muss ob hier nicht in der arbeitsrechtliche verfügung mal auch angemessen wäre keine ahnung was da jetzt konkret politisch passiert aber so kann es natürlich nicht bleiben.
Und da ist das ist natürlich auch eine versagen der der enter so wenn ich schon die leute ins land lassen was ich sicherlich richtig finde bevor das ganze zeug.
Irgendwie auf den feldern verdorrt oder dort jetzt ich weiß nicht wie viel tausend tiere,
ja tonnenweise fleisch vernichtet werden müsste das wäre sicherlich die schlechte alternative aber mein gott ich meine,
da kann man doch wenigstens noch irgendwie zwanzig oder dreißig euro am tag drauflegen für eine unterkunft wo die leute sich nicht gegenseitig anstecken aber gut egal wir waren eigentlich bei dem.
Vergleich,
als berliner natürlich immer so der blick auf die berliner bezirke auch auch immer ganz interessant jetzt die rangieren so im mittelfeld manchmal beziehungsweise auch.
Weit verteilt von platz zwanzig bis platz zweihundertzwanzig in der tabelle und.
Ja dafür dass es so eine große stadt ist ist es jetzt gar nicht so schlecht bis auf ihm zwei bezirke spandau und neukölln
und was man aber auch sagen muss dass sich berlin dass sich alle bezirke schlechter als das gesamtfeld entwickeln das heißt
alle sind aufgestiegen seit gestern so im schnitt um zehn
bis zwanzig plätze so größenordnungsmäßigen nach oben und das ist natürlich schon mal so einen warnzeichen so bei aller lang skepsis
was die daten angeht und mögliche verzerrungen aber wenn zwölf bezirke.
Alle nach oben rücken im vergleich zum gesamtfeld dann kann das nicht gut sein.
Ja das das ist so wobei wir ja noch mit vergleichsweise niedrigen zahlen agieren.
Ja das kann man auch sagen es ist nach wie vor auf einem vertretbaren level wie gesagt bis auf spandau und neukölln da also
gut es geht also es ist noch nicht schlimm spannend aus platz zwanzig grade von platz neununddreißig hochgegangen in
in deutschland und es spielt natürlich auch immer einen erwartungsschwere mit rein und vielleicht auch an der stelle für die leute die vielleicht.
Die letzten sendungen jetzt nicht gehört haben oder nicht so.
Vertraut damit sind wie denn dieses ranking jetzt eigentlich zustande kommt und im.
Wesentlichen versucht dieses ranking zu.
Berechnen wie viele ansteckende maximal so rumlaufen gerade in der in der stadt so und.
Brandau hat jetzt eins zu vierhundertneunundvierzig das heißt so lang maximal aktuell jeder vierhundertneunundvierzig könnte gerade ansteckend sein und die berechnung ist halt eher auf der.
Gefährlichen seite das heißt es ist eher ein eher einen maximum.
Eine pessimistische annahme sozusagen.
Eher eine pessimistische annäherung aber geht geht eben von dem aktuellen.
Stand wie viele fälle ist in den letzten sieben tagen gegeben hat aus guckt wie viel fälle waren's in den sieben tagen davor berechnet daraus ein trend und schreibt diesen trend nochmal um eine woche.
Vor dann wird das ganze nochmal mit einem faktor multipliziert nämlich dem dunkelziffer faktor wo man ausgehen muss im moment
ist der als sechs komma zwei fünf gefehlt das heißt sechs komma zwei fünf mal so viel leute sich infizieren wie in der statistik ausgewiesen
und dann teilt man sagen diese zahl der bevölkerung durch diese zahl und dann.
Bekommt man ungefähr den risiko wert den man halt auch ein bisschen lesen kann also sprich wenn dieser wert eins zu tausend ist dann heißt es etwa dass in jedem zehnten vollbesetzten.
So ein infizierten sitzen kann beispielsweise so kann man sich das in etwa vorstellen.
Wenn wenn die busse voll besetzt sind.
Wenn die busse voll besetzt sind ich hatte gehört dass gerade öh n v nicht so angesagt ist ich meide es
generell auch interessanterweise taxen haben gerade auch ein problem so die sind nicht besonders nachgefragt ich musste.
Jetzt gestern mal ein taxi bemühen und der taxifahrer war am klagen und mein werkstatt die halt hauptsächlich taxis repariert
da läuft das geschäft gerade auch nicht so gut die konnten wir das also bestätigen so also nicht nur busse und bahnen sondern auch taxen.
Wenig überraschend also das.
Ist klar alles alles wo es jetzt eng ist und wo man sich in unmittelbarer nähe zu unbekannten befindet über einen zeitraum von der viertelstunde
das ist halt taxi und das ist bus und bahn und alles und ja von daher können wir noch ein paar mehr radwege gebrauchen wenn ich zu sein.
Ja allerdings ist auch der autoverkehr hat deutlich zugenommen jetzt merkt man also ich hatte das gefühl es ist teilweise manchen stellen jetzt schlimmer als vor corona.
Soweit bin ich noch nicht gehen aber es ist auf jeden fall auf dem level wieder angekommen gute gelegenheit nochmal kurz auf diese mobility statistiken zu schauen guck mal kurz wie sich das hier in berlin entwickelt hat.
Geht langsam wieder nach oben also angeblich noch nicht wieder da wo wir mal waren aber tut sich auf jeden fall was.
Vor allem das fahren also das fahren ist jetzt laut apple bei minus zwanzig prozent im vergleich zu mitte märz.
Ok ja also.
Sagt zusammengefasst situationen es wird weniger es geht zurück aber nicht überall und es gibt brandherde und wir müssen aufpassen so also es ist nicht überall unter kontrolle.
Das heißt du hast an deiner tabelle weitergeschrieben in der letzten woche.
Ja
Die ist ja auch ist auf interesse gestoßen kann man sagen ne also du hast ja auch ein paar interessante anfragen bekommen.
Doch ja auf auf jeden fall also zum einen sicherlich oft fitter ich habe aber auch einige anfragen von journalisten bekommen die erklärt haben wollten was das denn so damit auf sich.
Und was ich denn da so so tue also ja es interesse ist auf jeden fall,
da und ich finde für mich macht das die situation jetzt wo wir in dieser neuen phase sind einfach auch
greifbarer so deswegen freue ich mich halt dass es eben funktioniert es hat man in der ersten woche ja.
Eine ganze weile gebraucht bis das einigermaßen robust war mit dem ranking und haben auch einige hörer oder auch leute auf twitter doch geholfen mit hinweisen über.
Ihre landkreise wo es dann entweder sie aus der presse andere situationen ihn bekannt waren oder.
Wo sie darauf gestoßen sind dass es ganz andere zahlen auf seiner landkreis seite ausweist und.
Darüber über diese hinweise bin ich dann tiefer in die daten eingestiegen und habe versucht dann rauszufinden wo denn dann diese unterschiede herkommt weil im großen und ganzen meistens stimmten die zahlen,
ziemlich genau mit denen vom beine aber es gab immer so einzelne fälle da waren die meine zahlen völlig anders so,
und.
Was dann dabei rausgekommen ist ist die interessante erkenntnis dass bei der art und weise wie jetzt,
die die landkreis zahlen auf der seite die täglichen präsentiert werden.
Das dabei faktisch fälle unter den tisch fallen die dort niemals.
Angezeigt werden das ist jetzt keine böse absicht weil sich jemand verschworen hat und fälle verheimlichen will das hat einfach damit zu tun mit.
Der frage okay was sind jetzt eigentlich fälle der letzten sieben tage was ist denn die definition davon und.
Man kann jetzt sagen.
Wir zählen einfach davon ich erstmal naiv ausgegangen wird zählen einfach die fälle die gemeldet werden.
Die melde zahlen genau die hatte ich zuerst genommen einfach nur so das problem war nur.
Dass manchmal ich irgendwo hundert hundertfünfzig fälle plötzlich drin hatte für einen für einen landkreis.
Wo ich dann.
Sowohl beim geguckt habe da waren dann irgendwie sieben und dann auf den landkreis geguckt habt und da war auch eigentlich ruhe und ich konnte mir das halt,
jetzt nicht erklären und.
Habe dann in die daten geguckt und der punkt war dass dann ja in den letzten sieben tagen da ist dann plötzlich an einem tag einen schwung von hundert fällen reingekommen die,
wenn da hundert fälle reinkommen dann,
dachte ich halt sind das hundert fälle so allerdings wenn man sich dann genau angeguckt hat wann denn das melde datum beim gesundheitsamt wiederum von diesen fällen war.
Stellte sich raus dass die über.
Wochen teilweise monate einige dieser fälle zurücklagen das will man natürlich nicht in einem aktuellen ranking haben so diese fälle aber ja was denn nun jetzt
zählt jetzt das eingangs datum wann gezählt wird oder das melde datum und.
Was das zu machen scheint ist dass sie halt die fälle aus den letzten sieben tagen nehmen.
Und zählen wenn das meldedaten auch innerhalb der letzten sieben tage liegt was natürlich.
Dazu führt dass wenn ein fall länger als sieben tage braucht von der meldung beim gesundheitsamt bis zur meldung beim was.
Eine menge fälle betrifft so dann taucht er halt nie auf weil sagt alles was sieben tage weiter zurück.
Liegt so ist halt für die für den letzten sieben tage schnitt irrelevant.
Lass mich doch mal kurz mal einhaken weil ich glaube das ist jetzt das ist wirklich ein ein punkt der nochmal betont gehört ich blätter nochmal ganz kurz zurück ich glaube vor drei wochen hattest du ja mal begonnen dieses now casting nachzuzeichnen.
Und deine daten basieren ja auf diesen sogenannten daten das ist im prinzip eine liste aller fälle
also eine detaillierte der detailliertes datensatz den das überhaupt herausgibt dann hast du angefangen dir das mal genauer anzuschauen das haben wir ja hier besprochen und dabei war dann vor allem erstmal entscheidend ist gab halt
bei jedem datensatz ein melde datum wann sozusagen dieser fall erfasst wurde,
und das bezieht sich aber auf den eingang beim richtig.
Nein beim gesundheitsamt.
Beim gesundheitsamt okay gut so außerdem war in diesem datensatz das erkrankungen datum oder zumindest gibt es ein feld dafür wann also wirklich diese person tatsächlich symptomatisch geworden ist.
Und um sozusagen alles etwas realistischer.
Darzustellen bisher losgegangen hast gesagt okay dann nehme ich doch einfach mal das erkrankung datum weil wenn etwas verspätet gemeldet wird dann,
heißt es zwar dass wir später davon erfahren haben aber um die aktuelle situation zu beurteilen muss man natürlich schon mal schauen wann ist denn das überhaupt passiert war was interessiert mich jetzt das meldet datum dabei.
Dabei fiel dann auf
dass sich bestimmte dinge nicht wieder herstellen lassen wenn man eben nicht im komplettes archiv der daten der letzten tage verfügt weil jeder datensatz sowie er täglich rausgegeben wird ein gewisser hinsicht bestimmte alte informationen unter schlägt oder nicht mehr so einfach zuzuordnen sind
dann hattest du das erstmal aufgegeben mit diesem snow casting in der zwischenzeit hast du diese daten fortwährend archiviert sodass das ja jetzt auch wieder möglich wäre dann kam aber hier diese idee mit
der risiko tabelle das hatte jetzt erstmal den fokus und da ist auch dieses
now casting also dieses herausrechnen der erkrankung daten erstmal so nicht drin gewesen und ist auch immer noch nicht drin richtig.
Nein das ist.
Hast du es jetzt mittlerweile.
Nein.
Ist es nicht drin okay.
Nein es ist nicht drin die lösung die ich dann gewählt habe um sagen denn von letztlich ist ja der der sinn und zweck einen vernünftiges ranking hinzukriegen und am ende haben wir.
Ohnehin.
Sag mal zehn tage melde verzug im schnitt ja das heißt wir gucken sowieso immer in die vergangenheit das heißt selbst wenn es jetzt zeilen der letzten sieben tage sind ja.
Sind es nicht wirklich leute die in den letzten sieben tagen erkrankt sind oder nur wenige davon so und was ich jetzt.
Der einfachheit halber gemacht habe ich habe für die meldungen den meldeschlusszeit verlängert das heißt ich zähle jetzt meldungen auch.
Für die letzten sieben tage die in den letzten sieben tagen eingetroffen sind beim aber ich erlaube dass das meldet datum zwei wochen zurückliegt.
Aber jetzt da wollt ihr jetzt nochmal kurz einhaken melde datum und melde datum also jetzt haben wir irgendwie auf einmal zwei meldedaten wir haben ein melde datum wann wurde der fall beim gesundheitsamt bekannt beziehungsweise dort erfasst.
Und dann haben wir melde datum wann wurde diese information an das weitergegeben.
Beziehungsweise vom veröffentlicht was sie dann immer sagen am folgetag oder um mitternacht machen das man könnte auch veröffentlichungsparty datum.
Zu sagen wann dieser fall öffentlich in die statistik eingeht also die täglichen fälle die wir immer in der summe kriegen beruhen
auf dem eingangs datum beim und nicht auf dem meldet datum.
Okay aber dieses veröffentlichung selber ist jetzt nicht nochmal ein feld in dieser liste sondern das ist schließt du quasi im prinzip daraus wann dieser datensatz das erste mal auf dieser webseite in diesem datenbestand auftaucht.
Genau ich gehe da mittlerweile jetzt fast an die zwanzig von diesen tages- dampft die alle eigentlich alle jeder dump enthält alle meldungen aber es fehlt halt dass
eingangs datum beim oder das veröffentlichung datum für die.
Vergangenen fälle so aber und ich gehe halt alle falten datensätze die mir vorliegen gehe ich halt durch und ergänze sie um ein feld eben veröffentlichung datum.
Oh mann ey krass gut okay nur nur dass wir mal unsere terminologie hier klar haben also wir haben im prinzip
drei daten über die wir jetzt reden wir haben das erkrankungen wir haben das melde datum das ist gesundheitsamtes wir haben das veröffentlichung datum das ist dann wenn es öffentlich macht so okay gut
und jetzt wieder zurück zu deiner berechnung.
Du ziehst jetzt welche informationen konkret daran also das erkrankung statue weil es potenziell zu sehr in der vergangenheit liegt das spielt jetzt hier noch keine rolle.
Ja und weil auch nur ungefähr die hälfte der fälle eins hat oder zwei drittel ungefähr haben überhaupt.
Ok aber da haben wir ja gesehen hast ja vor drei wochen erzählt dass man
das ja im prinzip auch hochrechnen kann weil man eben wenn man sich die anderen anschaut dann kann man quasi die verteilung auf die drauflegen die eben noch keine erkrankungen datum haben aber das würde jetzt wahrscheinlich auch in der aussage der tabelle nicht viel ändern aber entscheidend ist jetzt hier das melde datum
nicht das veröffentlichung datum.
Beide also sozusagen als fälle der letzten sieben tage gelten veröffentlichung datum in den letzten sieben tagen melde datum in den letzten vierzehn tagen so.
Und das macht das aber anders.
Das nimmt nur veröffentlichung datum letzte sieben tage melde datum letzte sieben tage.
Okay das heißt wenn jetzt ein.
Eine woche lang nicht anders weiter reicht dann dann dann fällt er quasi beim dann wird er beim nicht als existent veröffentlicht.
Jedenfalls nicht unter dem fall der letzten sieben tage ergeht
in den sozusagen gesamtschule ein also er wird dann auf die zahl der gesamtfeld zu sagen die turtles
da wird da drauf addiert aber er erzählt nicht als fall der letzten sieben tage mehr sozusagen durchgerutscht und die sieben tage ist natürlich mein.
Leute melden sich müssen dann
getestet werden dann muss es das testergebnis geben dann muss das testergebnis erfasst und dann muss es halt weitervermittelt werden interessanterweise kriegen es einige enter alles am selben tag hinten leute kommen hin,
kriegen einen test.
Das testergebnis und sie geben es ein und melden uns also es gibt einige gesundheitsamts wie es machen weiß ich nicht aber die kriegen das alles so ruckzuck hin und dann gibt's andere,
die scheinen fälle irgendwo in irgendwelchen kisten in irgendwelchen abstellkammern
zu verlieren oder zu lagern oder zu vergessen oder ich weiß es nicht ich meine keine ahnung wie situation ist aber anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären dass irgendwann plötzlich so ein schwung von hundert fällen kommt
so zwei monate halt zurückzufliegen.
Könntest du nicht für jeden landkreis so eine art trägheit zahl berechnen.
Habe ich auch schon im also es gibt auch schon einen eintrag dafür es gibt halt auch schon ein feld ich muss halt nur gucken.
Was ich damit mache es ist natürlich es kann natürlich dann leicht unfair werden weil ich kenne die situation vor ort nicht es kann bestimmte.
Gründe dafür geben warum das so ist aber ich denke ich werde trotzdem demnächst auch metriken
einbauen die so die laufzeit angeht ein bisschen kann man es schon sehen
an dem letzte meldung vorbei auf landkreisebene ist das ist es auch nicht so unbedingt aussagekräftig da kann wirklich kein fall
dabei gewesen sein aber interessant ist es aus manchen bundesländern auch zwei tage lang kein fall kommt oder einen tag lang kein fall kommt das ist dann schon ein bisschen naja
aber ja also die wollte ich auf jeden fall auch analysieren und wollte
will aber mal gucken wie die zu interpretieren sind dann die daten und was man daraus für schlüsse ziehen kann.
Ja also ich meine muss ja nicht gleich alles anfangen rot zu blinken deswegen aber ich würde sagen wenn man so eine zahl mal sieht die in irgendeiner form die durchschnittliche verzögerung der meldung
ausdrückt dass man das dann vielleicht mal korreliert mit ja wie viele fälle haben die denn überhaupt insgesamt also ist das sozusagen eine unmittelbare folge der
der problematik dass dort einfach viel zu zu traden und zu verfolgen und zu dokumentieren ist ja oder.
Fast gar keine fälle die denken sich so auch naja nächste woche melden so wird's wahrscheinlich nicht sein aber.
Irgendeine erklärung irgendeine erklärung muss es ja geben so.
Und auf jeden fall könnten so ein paar statistiken darüber ein bisschen für aufhellung
sagen und vielleicht dann in zukünftige prozessoptimierung
einfließen weil eigentlich müsste man jetzt als bundesregierung sind konzertierten programm zur überarbeitung der kompletten meldestraße turen,
einführen die es ermöglicht in echtzeit zu melden ich glaube das habe ich mir auch schon mehrfach bemerkt diese ganzen prozesse mit den gesundheitsämtern und so das ist nicht dafür gedacht täglich meldungen zu produzieren.
Also was du jetzt noch nicht kennst weil es nämlich gerade bevor wir jetzt mit dieser aufnahme begonnen haben
auch noch nicht veröffentlicht habe aber aufgenommen habe ist ein anderes gespräch also die ukw folge jetzt vor dieser folge habe ich mich mit jemandem unterhalten der jetzt ausgehend auf 'ner idee die auf diesem bier versus virus hacker von entstanden ist tatsächlich eine software macht für ein gesundheitsamtes in zusammenarbeit mit
einem gesundheitsamt und da haben wir ein bisschen darüber gesprochen wie dort die realität ist und die realität ist halt so
naja also die digitalisierung ist im wesentlichen excel
und leute schreiben mal zahlen ins brett rein das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt für jedes gesundheitsamt gelten aber es gibt jetzt auf jeden fall keine allgemeine software mit der sowas gemacht wird und der versuch an der stelle ist jetzt überhaupt erstmal
den stress auch von den dresdnern zu nehmen die ja unter anderem auch damit beschäftigt sind.
Alle leute die sie gerade beobachten also alle aktiven fälle und dass ihr nicht nur die neuen fälle sondern eben über einen zeitraum
einer dann verhängte quarantäne über die leute auch regelmäßig zu kontaktieren zweimal am tag zu fragen wie geht es ihnen und so weiter um das eben auch noch alles zu erfassen und um da mal ein bisschen automatisierung reinzubekommen.
Gibt's jetzt da
dieses open source projekt was versucht da zu helfen das ist jetzt alles gerade noch ganz am anfang muss man mal gucken wie sich das entwickelt aber kurz gesagt es gibt da einen erheblichen optimierung
also man kann da viel noch verbessern und es ist einfach nicht so dass es ein einheitliches system
für's dressing gebe oder so eine einheitliche support infrastruktur geschweige denn ebenso eine automatische meldung und das tut offensichtlich dringend notwendig gesundheitsämtern sind jetzt auch.
Auch in einer neuen situation weil bisher war es halt noch nie so akut so und wir wissen solche krisen werden dann auch dafür sorgen dass es besser wird.
Ich sage immer es ist unser allererster pandemien und es ist auch für die gesundheitsämtern die erste pandemien ist nicht so dass sie nicht,
gewohnt sind epidemien andere ausbrüche zu
unter kontrolle zu halten aber das sind dann einfach ganz kleine zahlen allerdings zum thema software in den gesundheitsämtern ich glaube da ist die situation auch sehr unterschiedlich ich weiß dass verschiedene bundesländer.
Auch bestimmte standardlösungen die auch wohl gar nicht so schlecht sind haben.
Wo sie teilweise dinge erfassen aber genau in einblick habe ich da nicht und dann ist natürlich generell im gesundheitswesen
wir haben's mit halt sehr sensiblen daten zu tun da gelten halt sehr hohe anforderungen an den datenschutz
das ist halt nicht ganz so.
Einfach glaube ich das zu verändern und generell sich anguckt so die ganzen großen projekte im gesundheitswesen man da reden wir dann auch
dass ich jetzt wenn's um krankenkassen geht oder systeme von von system die dann mit
millionen kunden umgehen müssen und super sensiblen daten von sich millionen von von leuten
das dauert halt in der regel jahre bis da was gebaut wird und das ist alles sehr sehr schwierig und schwerfällig aber generell eigentlich wär's
an der an der zeit dann auch mal den gesundheitsämtern das wird bestimmt auch erfolgen oder erfolgt auch mehr geld zu geben und sich aber vor allen dingen zu überlegen
wie man denn da melden kann ich glaube andere länder die haben das ein bisschen schneller auf die reihe gekriegt so ich habe mir mal die osterreicht.
Angeschaut die haben zwar erst etwas später angefangen daten zu erfassen und haben dann aber gleich einen meldesystem offenbar aufgesetzt was mehr relevante daten
erfasst und die auch ein bisschen schneller erfasst zum beispiel keine ahnung genau was sie da am start haben aber.
Das sah halt so aus als wenn die da mal eben schnell was auf die beine gestellt haben zur erfassung was besser geeignet ist.
So oder so war es eine gute idee mal euch alle aufzufordern mal den eigenen landkreis ein bisschen zu verfolgen da sind auch noch ein paar kommentare aufgelaufen weiß nicht ob du die schon alle nachgearbeitet hast in der shownotes der
sendung in den kommentaren gab's auch noch mal so ein paar paar hinweise für einzelne landkreise kann also durchaus sein und das ist ja hier generell der disclaimer.
Kann durchaus sein dass hier auch noch ein paar dinge durcheinander geraten sind entweder weil man irgendwas übersehen hat in der berechnung der algorithmus vielleicht dann doch nicht ganz so passt für extremfälle oder eben wie man jetzt auch gerade gehört hat
das ist einfach so diskrepanzen gibt mit dem wie andere leute die selben zahlen interpretieren
konkret eben das und das muss immer alles noch mit eingearbeitet werden also keeper coming.
Also ich gucke ich gucke dann mir solche sachen schon auch an sehr häufig und guckt dann an okay was ist denn jetzt in den in den daten eigentlich was denn gekommen anmeldungen zu dem
bezirk und.
Sehr häufig sind es jetzt einfach fälle wo schon mal die lokale presse oder der lokale kreis schon daten auf ihrer webseite veröffentlicht hat aber das weiß noch nichts davon so
und die sind halt dann noch nicht übermittelt offenbar
nicht in der daten lieferung bisher drin da kann man dann ausgehen dass die hoffentlich so dann relativ zeitnah dass sich das so ein zwei tage später dann bereinigt
aber ja ich versuche das so ein bisschen im im blick zu behalten was ich da tut und ja wie gesagt man stößt dann auf ja
interessante dinge die man so nicht gedacht hätte was die zahlen betrifft und wie sie zustande kommen und zusammenhängen.
Wir sind ja auch nicht der einzige die unglücklich sind es ist jetzt ein offener brief ergangen an das der open.
Corona data
ich hatte davon auch im vorfeld mitbekommen habe allerdings dann drauf verzichtet da noch mit zu unterschreiben da waren wir schon genug prominent daten journalisten dabei
vielleicht mal ganz interessant hier die forderung nochmal nachzugehen weil ja auch sehr,
grete forderungen gestellt werden also das ganze ist ein brief an den herrn vila also die präsidenten des und wird halt generell beklagt mit wir wollen ja hier gerne auch helfen wir wollen ja auch gerne mal reinschauen wir wollen vor allem auch verstehen wir wollen auch missverständnisse verhindern
und davon gab es ja nun in der letzten zeit so
einige gerade im hinblick auf diese ganze debatte mit was was ist denn hier überhaupt die wahrheit und was nicht schwabler und ähnliche problematiken gut da gibt's eine menge leute denen kann man es in die recht machen und die wollen auch die wahrheit nicht unbedingt sehen aber es hat trotzdem gut wenn man eben auch wirklich
nachweisen kann und ich denke das hat ja deine tabelle auch gezeigt es gibt so viele blickwinkel die man einnehmen kann auf die situation.
Wo das auf würde ich sagen einfach total überfordert ist klar die haben so die aufgabe so eine so eine so eine hauptsaal zu errechnen und sonst light idee auch daraus.
Zu leiten und als beratung beratende leistung dem der bundesregierung.
Bereitzustellen das ist ja auch die aufgabe des aber es ist halt sehr wertvoll hier auch andere perspektiven zu ermöglichen um einfach vielleicht probleme zu entdecken.
Die sonst einfach gar keine entdeckte da einfach weil's die daten hergeben,
also hier heißt es dann also bitte mach mal und wir haben hier ein daten katalog angehangen was für den ganz gerne hätten damit es besser ist.
Und das würde ich ganz gerne mal kurz mit dir durchgehen also punkt a offenlegung der datenspeichern der korona daten des.
Soweit in abstimmung mit dem erstellt der gesundheitsbehörden in deutschland.
Also namen der datenbanken angaben der merkmale beziehungsweise spalten metadaten und dokumentation.
Ja das kann ich auch voll unterschreiben es wäre super erstmal zu wissen was sie denn überhaupt alles haben.
Das wäre einfach hilfreich also muss man sich das einfach anschauen und da so was heißt denn das eigentlich ne punkt de.
Die folgenden daten sollten generell tagesaktuell als zeitreihe und regional so fein wie möglich aufgegliedert und veröffentlicht werden.
Das datenformat sollte maschinen lesbar und immer gleich strukturiert sein.
Als vorbild kann der daten hab neunzehn dienen im.
Die daten die du ja auch verwendest ne wo immer möglich wäre es wünschenswert in diesem datensatz die genannten neuen merkmale einzupflegen datensätze sollen nicht überschrieben alte versionen erhalten bleiben.
Ja
Haben wir ja auch schon hier mehrfach betont und auch vorhin auch nochmal kurz beschrieben.
So dazu punkt eins bereitstellung aller anonymisierten datensätze der epidemie insbesondere des infektionsgefahr als vollständige auch historische.
Zeit rein insbesondere fallzahlen mit importierten krankheitsbedingt.
Erkrankungen beginn.
Importiert was sind das für ein wort importiert.
Ja letztlich,
ist es so dass sie das für die fälle einfach sie nennen das importieren dass da in den fällen wo der wo kein erkrankungsrisiko.
Eingetragen ist oder bekannt ist werden halt diese fälle mich das auch gemacht habe.
Statistisch nach einer bestimmten verteilung auf die vergangenheit verteilt so weil man weiß zwei drittel der fälle
hatten die und die verspätungen sich zehn prozent waren am ersten tag da dreißig prozent am zweiten tag fünfzig prozent am dritten tag und ende der woche waren es achtzig prozent
oder sechzig prozent und wie auch immer so
und so werden dann halt die fälle mit unbekannten erkrankungen beginn s statistisch genauso verteilt
da ja kann man reinpacken also wer nicht schlecht die haben die die die werte.
Aber da würde mich halt vor allen dingen dann auch interessieren.
Sagen dieses verspätung profil dürfte sich sehr stark unterscheiden von bundesland zu bundesland und von kreis zu kreis sogar und da ist dann sozusagen die frage,
differenziert man da halt auch noch weiter aber auf jeden fall sollten sie das was sie da rechnen ruhig auch mit reinpacken als als zusätzliches feld des tut niemandem weh und ja.
Ja dann würden zumindest mal alle auswertungen auch auf derselben annahme basieren so.
Ja also ist jetzt nicht kriegsentscheidend weil das kann man relativ einfach selber machen wenn die anderen daten vorliegen so ist das jetzt nicht so schwierig.
Gut dann sterben mit sterbedatum.
Ja das wäre auch ganz nett.
Fallzahlen mit zusätzlichen kategorien nach infektionsschutz gesetz diverse paragraphen von dreiundzwanzig bis zweiundvierzig wie im lagebericht dargestellt zum beispiel nach arbeitsstationen oder wohnverhältnisse der positiv getesteten
personen.
Ja das ist natürlich etwas was es also.
Ich glaube nicht dass diese daten bisher im moment tatsächlich.
Alle erfasst werden ich bin mir da eigentlich nicht sicher so also ich habe jedenfalls kein hinweis dass jetzt arbeitsstationen und
verhältnisse elektronisch
erfasst werden bisher das wäre wahrscheinlich eher was wo auch die gesundheitsämtern dann wahrscheinlich
also wo halt nachgearbeitet werden müsste aber wäre natürlich super wünschenswert fall oder super wertvoll auf jeden fall für die nächste pandemien.
Die genießen mit dem bereits vorliegenden echten oder geschätzten genesungs-update ersetzt durch die angaben aus den erweiterten meldepflichten sobald diese vorliegen.
Das ist natürlich eine wichtige information wenn man die hätte um die auslastung des gesundheitssystems besser abschätzen.
Zu können ist aber natürlich jetzt auch schon fast gelaufen nur bei gut zweite welle kriegen aber das ist halt ein schwieriges thema.
Mit der auslastung des gesundheits-
Es geht ja auch nicht unbedingt immer nur um die aktuelle situation so also allein um das alles auch immer im nachgang nachrechnen zu können wäre das ja ganz interessant daran wird sich sicherlich einiges ablesen lassen können so und dann altersgruppen so genau wie möglich
idealerweise fünf alters jahre also nehmen wir mal an das meint jetzt in so fünf jahres blöcken.
Ja es gibt da schon ein feld für einmal es gibt halt die
normalen altersgruppen da jetzt glaube ich sechs verschiedene und dann gibt's eigentlich noch einen feld schon bereits oder es gab einen feld namens altersgruppe zwei die noch ein bisschen feiner aufgeschlüsselt war das haben sie aber irgendwann rausgenommen.
Okay
alle zeitstempel im ablauf des meldet verfahrens also eingang der meldung beim gesundheitsamt erkrankungen zeitpunkt datenweitergabe an land datenweitergabe an veröffentlichung,
durch das.
Genau das was wir vorhin besprochen haben wobei jetzt hier noch ein paar punkte dazu kommen was ich auch übersehen hatte ist natürlich dass es gesundheitsamtes ans meldet sondern ans land und das land meldet ans.
Das könnte auch erklären was du vorhin meintest mit ganze länder sind ein bisschen später dran da könnt ihr es einfach sein dass dass die länder selber einfach einen verzögerung haben das ist gar nicht mal so sehr an den gesundheitsämtern liegt.
Gut dann zwei tägliche angaben zu testung und deren ort b arztpraxis oder stationen,
krankenhaus getesteten personen mit geschlecht und altersgruppe
positiven testergebnissen anzahl übermitteln der labore und test kapazitäten anzahl von laboren mit rückstau dessen ausmaß abzuarbeiten proben ausmaß von lieferschwierigkeiten.
Der betroffenen artikel okay da gehe ich aber jetzt in die vollen das mit den testung hatten wir letzte woche auch schon also das
ist natürlich eine sehr sinnvolle zahl allein um da eben entsprechende kalibrierung der meldet zahlen vorzunehmen und es ist natürlich auch
grundsätzlich interessant und es leidet sich da mehr oder weniger draus
ab einfach mal zu schauen welche verhältnis steht denn das ganze also wie oft wird getestet und wie viele fallzahlen oder
infektionen zahlen sind jetzt daraus hervor gegangen.
Also das,
wäre also es gibt da länder hatten wir halt halt auch schon so ein paar als vorbild ich glaube singapur korea südkorea
da hast du täglich zwar jetzt nicht.
Nicht so weit runter gerechnet auf einzelne testlabor aber was schon mal hilft ist wie viele leute haben sich an dem tag.
Gemeldet und haben einen test bekommen wie viele tests sind an dem tag
gemacht worden aber dessen ergebnis ist noch nicht bekannt und ja dann natürlich dass das ergebnis so wie viele tests sind zurückgekommen
mit welchem ergebnis und das ist natürlich unerlässlich.
Das zu haben um so dinge wie was wir halt vorhin.
Am anfang hatten das thema die regeln werden geändert jetzt werden plötzlich gesundheitspersonal getestet es gibt.
Siebzehn prozent mehr tests auf einmal.
Einer woche und dann ja passen natürlich die zahlen von vorher und nachher nicht zusammen und dann rechnet man aber aus den vorher und nachher zahlenden was natürlich kompletter quatsch ist.
So
Also das ist ein ganz ganz wichtiges ding die testung müssen einfach dabei sein sonst sind die zahlen also ja halt so wie sie sind im moment.
Forderung drei die genaue schätzung von r mit konferenz intervallen die anscheinend auch auf landesebene zur verfügung gestellt wird wie zum beispiel für berlin.
Ja das ist überhaupt das ding also wir haben jetzt diese starken unterschiede wenn man dein tabelle anschaut wird relativ klar also wenn man sich so die die top-talente anschaut
dann ist das im wesentlichen bayern thüringen nordrhein-westfalen und baden-württemberg,
wobei coming ab bremen mit einem landkreis jetzt auch einmal auch in der top aber das mag kann nur kurzfristige geschichte sein aber es ist relativ klar dass ich die südländer dann kommt halt.
Hessen langsam rein so und dauert einfach eine weile
platz einundvierzig da geht's dann erstmal mit niedersachsen das erste mal los und bis dann halt überhaupt erstmal berlin auftaucht oder schleswig-holstein vom osten gar nicht zu reden
dauert halt dann einfach ne weile sprich dieses er differenziert nach einzelnen
bundesländern zu machen wäre auf jeden fall eine sinnvolle information ist allerdings auch etwas was du ja aus deinen daten jetzt auch ausrechnen könntest.
Ja ich habe sogar gestern schon damit angefangen ist ein bisschen fummelig so sagen die.
Bundesländer mit
in die tabelle reinzupacken also vergleichbare werte für die gesamten bundesländer zu berechnen es ist super nützlich so weil erstens kann man dann sagen unter art.
Kommt dann demnächst auch bei für bundesland dann kann man halt sagen schnell sich die bundesländer angucken und auch in den bundesländern ranking
einfach machen und dann auch sehen ob eine landkreis im vergleich zum bundesland,
jetzt schlechter oder besser dasteht und.
Ein eintrag für gesamt deutschland auch mit vergleichbaren werten also es wird demnächst auch als feature kommen.
Was ist denn die art von deutschland staat.
Genau oder b s für bundesstaat.
Nicht nicht was du dachtest.
Naja weiter in der liste
der code hinter dem naujokat aber auch hinter veröffentlichung wie den beispiel szenarien der saß kopf zwei epidemie in deutschland ist der titel von dieser webseite nämlich an
auf also wir möchten gerne den code sehen wollen wir die die herleitung sehen und dann noch punkt fünf aus,
r workshop ist uns ferner bekannt dass das regelmäßig gesundheitsämtern abfragt wie groß die belastung ist die ergebnisse dieser regelmäßigen umfrage würden wir.
Gerne veröffentlicht.
Also das ist jetzt im prinzip die komplette forderung und im wesentlichen ist es macht man ordentliche daten formate haut mal alles raus was ja raushauen könnt wir wollen das mal genauer anschauen aber vor allem beschreibt man den scheiß ordentlich,
stellt sich mir übrigens auch gerade die frage hast du denn eigentlich auch schon mal drüber nachgedacht mal deinen code zu veröffentlichen.
Ja hatte ich werde ich wahrscheinlich ich habe auch glaube ich schon ich habe auch schon ein replay angelegt und ich meine
ich ja also er er kommt der der der code.
Der code kommt sehr schön ja das haben wir immer gerne dass der.
Das problem ist ja das problem ist ein bisschen dass man halt mit dem code ohne die daten nicht so richtig viel
anfangen kann und ich muss mal gucken wie das ist weil das sind halt schon mittlerweile je nachdem in welcher form da gut komprimiert also ich
ich bin mir noch nicht sicher wo ich die daten dann alle hinpacken ob ich hier auch dann ins gitter packe weiß ob das.
Sollte bei freien report sollte beim öffentlichen report sollte das gehen ja bei einem.
Was sollte da nicht gehen.
Na ja bei einem privaten report ist irgendwann zu viel,
traffic also da ist halt probleme in der zeit sind dann halt für.
Machst du halt public ich meine schmeiß einfach die daten rein dann ist sozusagen auch gleich ein dieses archiv dieser oder hatten das fehlt ja ohnehin schon du hast jetzt zwanzig tage und wer mal ganz cool wenn das report auch mal irgendwo verfügbar wäre.
Nee das ist eine gute idee ist halt dann wieder ein weiterer tag so gucken entweder features oder dann veröffentlichen und wo ich halt so ein bisschen angst habe gut vielleicht.
Rüttelt sich das ein ist das dann.
Halt natürlich leute fragen stellen und support wollen und irgendwie patches einschicken die dann das vielleicht wert sind so aber ich also eigentlich wollte ich jetzt kein neues großes open source projekt.
Starten so das war jetzt nicht.
Achso darum geht's ja auch nicht.
Aber ich werde ich werde sie
wahrscheinlich dann einfach raustun und auch das ding ist halt so im fluss wenn ich jetzt anfange das zu dokumentieren und schick zu machen und zu supporten komme ich halt nicht mehr
nicht mehr weiter aber vielleicht finden sich leute aber ich weiß auch nicht.
Im schlimmsten fall hast du selber einen ordentliches gitarre von dem ganzen kram das kann so schlecht nicht sein so und falls jemand lust hat da mal drauf zu schauen gerade bei den ganzen problemen mit den verwendeten fremdwort und so weiter könnt ihr auch hilfreich sein,
wo er noch bei forderungen als sind ist mir noch ein lustiger artikel tagesspiegel aufgefallen,
wo es heißt die grünen fordern ein klares test konzept soll fünf korona waren stufen einführen,
die höchste stufe bedeutet hotspot niedrige stufe so gut wie keine fälle wo sich das modell wohl abgeguckt haben naja wer weiß.
Ja bei uns heißen die du hast ja den begriff super rot und super grün eingeführt glaube ich so also wir haben hier zufällig auch also es gibt super grün grün gelb rot und super rot.
Das sind die fünf korona warnstufe.
Stufen aus der aus der aus der rangliste.
Gut damit sind wir glaube ich durch mit den zahlen richtig.
Vielleicht noch eine stimmt gar nicht wir sind noch nicht durch mit den zahlen aber kurzer hinweis auf andere quellen also erstmal viele von euch haben unserem.
Unserer frage mit wo kannst du noch interessante daten geben für andere länder auch einiges geschickt spoiler wir werden auch
diesmal nicht so detaillierten auslands auswertungen kommen reden aber gleich nochmal drüber bevor ich das mache wollte ich nochmal kurz hinweisen auf eine andere quelle die ich schon länger im auge habe aber die wir bisher noch relativ wenig erwähnt haben und zwar ist das die webseite auer world in data war dir das eigentlich vorher schon bekannt.
Pavel.
Ich glaube ich hatte mal davon gehört aber.
Podcast von mir davon gehört haben weil ich habe schon vor fünf jahren mal darüber berichtet.
Rahmen meines forschergeist podcasts ich mit dem stift der verband für die deutsche wissenschaft mache und mir ist das projekt relativ früh aufgefallen und als ich zu dem zeitpunkt gerade in sowieso in england gelebt habe
bin ich dann einfach mal nach ochs fahrt gefahren zu dem max rosa der das projekt gestartet hat und dass das ganze war eigentlich eine.
Mehr so ein hobby-projekt von ihm und ich habe mittlerweile so den eindruck dass sie das so komplett
ausfüllt weil konnte dann auch eine interviewanfrage von mir nur mit nee sorry.
Zu viele projekte gerade später vielleicht mal beantworten achtzehn die vermessung der welt und was aber grundsätzlich tut ist
das ist quasi so eine art meter webseite für studien die dinge über die welt abbilden und
wenn man auf die webseite geht sieht man da zu zahlreiche kategorien also alles abgebildet von umwelt und politische entwicklung und demokratie und armut und hunger und krankheiten und alles also gesundheit
kriege umwelt also einfach das volle speck
von wissenschaftlicher beobachtung der welt also der fokus ist studien die quasi die
gesamtsituation auf diesem planeten festschreiben und die werden dann halt alle zusammengesucht und
in einem kontext gestellt das heißt wenn man halt schauen will wie hat sich denn die armut entwickelt dann werden einfach alle studien
die aussagekräftig genug sind und derer werden kann werden dann zusammengesucht und die daraus resultierenden zahlen aggregiert und erhält halt auf dieser webseite quasi so die mieter auswertung aller studien.
Was halt für bestimmte dinge die einfach auch schon über hunderte und tausende von jahren erfasst werden können unfassbare zeit spektren abdeckt
andere sachen die noch nicht so lange erfasst werden oder deren thema noch nicht so lange relevant ist gehen dann halt entsprechend nur zehn zwanzig dreißig jahre zurück und
da kann man ein paar schöne sachen ablesen nämlich unter anderem das eigentlich eigentlich fast alles besser wird
das ist das interessante also gerade die ganzen gesellschaftlichen betrachtung armut und so weiter also es hat sich schon sehr viel verbessert auf diesem planeten natürlich haben wir gerade mit dem klimawandel und natürlich jetzt auch konkret mit dieser epidemie
dinge die sich nicht so gut entwickeln.
Nichtsdestotrotz war natürlich dann für das projekt auch sehr interessant und die haben sich da extrem schnell drauf
stürzt und sind mittlerweile als ich das vor fünf jahren das gespräch mit ihm geführt habe da war das einfach noch so ein kleines hobby-projekt und ja mal gucken und vielleicht kriege ich ja auch noch mal jemanden der mir so ein bisschen bei den grafiken hilft mittlerweile scheint das team etwas angewachsen zu sein wenn man auf world in delta
punkt org schaut findet man dort einfach ja extrem gute visualisierungen von allem möglichen und speziell
der bereich zu der corona pandemien ist natürlich jetzt extrem cool man hat diese grafiken wahrscheinlich auf twitter und überall schon mal gesehen.
Was ist ein bisschen schwierig gemacht hat das hat mir hier auch ich habe mal wieder versucht zu ja wo war denn jetzt hier diese grafik und diese auswertung et cetera die hatten so viel wie nichts mehr wiedergefunden hat
und jetzt gibt es aber den korona virus pandemien data explorer und das ist dann quasi für ihre ganzen meter sammlung nochmal die meter grafik.
Kann man also mal eben länder auswerten und kriegt dann kombinierte grafiken wo man
ja sich wirklich eine sehr interessante sichtweise auf alles besorgen kann.
Speziell haben sie eben diese per kapital auswertung und das ist ja so das was in dieser ganzen johns hopkins und sonstigen berichterstattung einfach immer wieder völlig ausreichend man macht einfach keinen sinn die todes zahlen
der usa und die todesfallen italiens nebeneinander zu halten weil diese länder einfach nicht ansatzweise vergleichbar sind
von der einwohnerzahl her also muss man das einfach immer alles relativieren hier kann man in dem datum explorer mal sagen okay.
Leiden wir mal hier alle länder sozusagen also was da mit dem outbreak losging die haben also alle mehr oder weniger so ein tag
null und dann sieht man eben schnell wie sich das den einzelnen ländern entwickeln hat und insbesondere wenn man die zahlen dann auf die einwohnerzahl normalisiert kriegt man wirklich mal einen eindruck davon wo es eigentlich.
Schlimm war und wo es muss wo es schwierig ist und wo länder wie die vereinigten staaten denn jetzt eigentlich gerade stehen.
Also da kann man sich ein paar wirklich sehr hilfreiche grafiken also ich finde zum beispiel den du gerade erwähnt hast den total confirm cases million people und mit gleichem anfang das
das hilft dann schon.
Mal genauer zu sehen also einfach eine bessere bessere vergleichsmöglichkeiten und was ich auch schick finde ist dass man gleich die daten auch runterladen kann.
So sie haben dann auch meistens immer irgendwie als als gier und dann einfach gleich dabei wenn man eine grafik sieht zack
ein klick und man kann die das ganze als csu runterladen und so.
Oder leicht scheren.
So soll es sein also das ist schon gefällt mir gut und hatte mich auch wenn.
Also eine idee war auch noch weil das mit dem ranking tatsächlich nochmal so eine.
Art und weise ist interessante art und weise um halt ganz viele verschiedene.
Fälle oder gegenden irgendwie in beziehung
zu setzen dass ich eventuell auch dann sagen sollen so ein global ranking aller nationen dann
alle staaten vielleicht nochmal angehen könnte wenn das hier wenn ich
genug genug features drin hab dann.
Ja das ganze nochmal auf andere daten oder auf die welt zu schmeißen fände ich ganz interessant zumal
ja auch in den verschiedenen ländern sich das zeitlich anders abspielt und dazu wissen auch jetzt für die urlaubs und reiseplanung und so.
Also ich habe jetzt hier mal testweise mal europäische länder also so zentral europa kanarien ich gucke gerade noch was fehlt mir noch
dänemark schon mal gerade alle nachbar länder deutschlands auch zusammenzubekommen polen frankreich
auch
spanien portugal schmeiße ich noch mit rein italien und was haben wir noch schweiz brauche ich noch und österreich und dann sieht man also ich blicke jetzt auf
turtelt konform cases also fallzahlen.
Lustig was denkst du was der spitzenreiter ist also welches land ist sozusagen in relation zur einwohnerzahl am meisten von fällen betroffen.
Also ich hatte belgien irgendwie in erinnerung dass die ganz gut dabei waren aber spanien ist glaube ich auch ganz weit oben aber du hast es ja schieß los.
Ich hab's jetzt hier bunt auf weiß genau und tatsächlich liegt spanien noch kurz vor belgien aber der totale ausreißer ist luxemburg also da
extrem viel fälle wobei man muss jetzt immer sagen fälle heißt was haben wir gefunden
wer viel sucht der findet viel und länder stehen hier ziemlich weit unten teilweise wo man sich denkt so ihr könnt mir viel erzählen wenn mich allerdings auf konform des gehe also die todeszone wo ich mal sagen würde die sind dann schon
bisschen aussagekräftiger weil sie sich halt nicht ganz so leicht verstecken lassen auch wenn.
Der fall zu sein scheint da ist allerdings belgien ganz weit vorne also belgien ist derzeit so mit achthundert,
pro eine million relativ weit vorne dann kommt spanien mit sechshundert und ja idealisten da liegt so bei knapp über.
Fünfhundert und ja aber juni ted kingdom ist da schon auf dem allerbesten weg die zu überholen und wird wahrscheinlich auch spanien überholen
es wird auch immer wieder darauf hingewiesen ich habe das mehrfach schon hier mal so auf twitter bemerkt so ja hier belgien hat ja hart getroffen und so kommt dann immer wieder der korrekte hinweis naja
die zählen vielleicht auch anders ne also wenn halt ein land sagt jemand war wegen kurve da ist gestorben aber man weiß nicht woran und ja dann dann
wird es einfach als kurve der,
gezählt während andere länder halt sagen naja also wenn es nicht bewiesen ist dass er daran gestorben ist dann kannst du auch hier lungenentzündungen gewesen sein das wird sich in der zukunft alles relativieren wenn man eben mal
die sterben zahl dieses jahres vergleichen mit den letzten jahren dann wird halt klar sein wer hier wirklich der große verlierer gewesen ist,
wer auch hier noch ganz gut dabei ist ist frankreich natürlich aber schweden ist auch schon direkt dahinter dann auch schon die niederlande und
states ist da auch dahinter aber die liegen halt noch nicht ansatzweise da wo jetzt spanien italien das
getroffen hat aber muss halt auch sagen die sind auch schon noch ein bisschen weiter bisschen weiter in dem ganzen programm.
Ja
Generell ich meine wir versprechen jetzt schon seit zwei sendungen dass wir die große auslands betrachtung machen und es ist nicht so dass ich da jetzt nicht auch schon einiges an zeit reingesteckt hätte so aber.
Es ist super super schwierig
wirklich länder miteinander zu vergleichen wenn man dann anfängt ins detail zu gehen also ich hatte halt sagt als erstes nicht auf schweden
gestürzt weil natürlich immer die frage ist weil es immer wieder in der presse auftaucht machen die schweden das jetzt irgendwie besser hätten wir keinen lok down gebraucht.
So und die situation in schweden so wenn man sich dort die zahlen anguckt die sind
total irre also da versuche ich mir halt gerade einen reim,
drauf zu machen aber.
So in schweden zum beispiel die zahl der toten ging halt erst rauf dann wieder runter
wieder rauf plötzlich kam irgendwie ein ganzer schwung von toten und so irgendwie die sie zahlen
geben im moment für mich vorne und hinten keinen sinn also jedenfalls nicht so viel sinn als dass ich in der lage wäre jetzt zu sagen so sieht's aus also wie gesagt ich habe halt angefangen.
So sieben tage durchschnitte mal für verschiedenen berechnungen und es fängt damit an letzte mal glaube ich auch schon das für alles für schweden,
plötzlich die zahl der toten anfing runterzugehen bevor die zahl der infizierten anfing zu sinken so das war völlig also.
Die kurven sind wirklich wild und quer durch den durch den wald und ohne zusätzliche informationen wie test zeilen oder was da tatsächlich los ist machen.
Die zahlen nicht nicht wirklich sinn also aber konkret kann man zumindest kann ich schon mal sagen den zahlen nach also was die zahlen im moment sagen ist.
Dass schweden in schweden nur
ganz kurzzeitig bisher mal für vier tage unter eins gewesen ist und dann mal für also vor ein paar wochen für einen tag unter eins dann wieder so eher bei eins komma eins lag und dann von der woche.
Wieder also tiefste auf auf null komma neun mal für drei tage gefallen ist und dann wieder auf eins komma zwei angestiegen und jetzt gerade aktuell ist es wieder.
Knapp unter eins gefallen so im also wenn man das das jetzt mit deutschland vergleich zum beispiel oder oder den trend jetzt fortschreiben würde dann kann man sagen dass noch nicht absehbar ist dass es in schweden
irgendwann aufhört im moment sondern das geht das bewegt sich zwar ganz leicht nach unten aber eigentlich kann man sagen
ist in schweden seit vier wochen
sind die im im schnitt die zahlen der infizierten unverändert ja da geht nichts runter so und das ist natürlich blöd.
Weil dann wenn's nicht runter geht sind die die nächsten drei jahre damit beschäftigt irgendwie aufzupassen.
So sieht es mit schweden gerade aus aber ob die zahlen stimmen ob.
Also diese was ich gerade gesagt habe dass ich das halt seitwärts bewegt ohne festgestellt haben bei uns ist es auch durch tests durch veränderungen bei den tests.
Massiv verschoben also da können anstiege oder abfälle scheinbar sein
weil sie jedem das testen verändert hat und das wäre jetzt bei schweden einfach unerlässlichen glaube da gibt es aber auch testfahren so und ohne das zu korrelieren macht es halt kaum sinn.
Wenn wir uns auf jeden fall nochmal
anschauen ich hatte jetzt in dem podcast mit dem herrn der beim mdr ja ist gab es ganz interessant ich habe immer noch keinen link zu dieser studie gefunden aber es wurde eine studie zitiert im der es hieß naja da hätte jetzt meine forschergruppe die deutschen zahlen mal ganz konkret nachgerechnet und
dann quasi sich ein modell ausgedacht was eben den tatsächlichen verlauf nachbildet also wir haben ja immer so dass
modell was in die zukunft schauen möchte in der vergangenheit ist halt einfacher weil dann kann man dann immer so ganz genau das anpassen und kriegt dann eben modell hin was eben dann exakt dieselben zahlen produziert auf basis derselben daten,
und dann haben sie aber mal geguckt wie ist denn das jetzt wie wäre es denn gewesen wenn wir jetzt mal fünf tage später oder fünf tage früher in den look down gegangen wären in deutschland.
Und ich fand das ziemlich krass die feststellung kann das halt jetzt nicht nachvollziehen ich zumindest jetzt erstmal so hin wie es gehört habe dass ja fünf tage später hätte bedeutet wir hätten viermal so viele fälle gehabt.
Was ganz ordentlich ist,
und aber noch krasser fand ich die aussage ja fünf tage früher und wir hätten wenn nie mehr als mehr als tausend fälle pro tag gekommen und.
Hätten wir uns unter umständen in kompletten look down damit gewisser hinsicht also den langen den langen zeitraum von lok down ersparen können.
Wir hatten also im grunde genommen wenn nun ordentlichen lok down machst der funktioniert das virus ist.
Bei den meisten leuten so für sieben meisten leute sind sieben acht tage ansteckend einige
etwas länger es können auch in einzelfällen zwei wochen oder so aber die zwei wochen quarantäne reicht eigentlich aus also eigentlich hätte es genügt das land hier für zwei wochen dicht zu machen was er wahrscheinlich nicht geht
und dann werden wir durch gewesen ja also zwei wochen richtig harten lok down keiner verlässt das haus aber das ist wahrscheinlich.
Eher unrealistisch.
Muss ja zumindest mal einkaufen gehen können so und dann hätte er natürlich auch einen ansturm auf die läden gehabt dass das das total chaos.
Ja wie gesagt ist wahrscheinlich eher theorie und du hast halt ganz viele dinge die du hast tiere zu versorgen kannst nicht sie ja.
Es gibt alles mögliche aber es ist klar hätte man jetzt mal so zwei wochen vorher schon gesagt ok großveranstaltungen wir machen jetzt hier mal
wir fahren mal runter und wir legen auch sag mal generell mehr eine alarmistische stimmung an tag wir haben ja gesehen was allein.
Die ansprache der bevölkerung gebracht hat ok gut das sind auch die bilder aus italien gewesen die hätte man jetzt nicht früher liefern können und es,
immer müßig im nachhinein zu sagen ja hätten wir hätten wir hätten mal.
Allen auch selber gemerkt wie wie lange das auch gedauert hat bis bis so eine situation,
bei allem auch erstmal ein sinkt ja also weiß doch alleine dieser dieser woche wo es dann hieße ja fußball könnte unter umständen nicht stattfinden aber auch noch sowas wie hier kein fußball und habt ihr sie noch alle,
hier ist doch nix so weißt du bis man dann so eine woche später so okay war vielleicht doch nicht so eine schlechte idee.
Waren wir eigentlich unsere erste sendung corona.
Das muss dann in der woche danach gewesen sein jetzt muss ich letzte selber mal schauen wir hatten die corona lok down sendung am.
Am dreizehnten märz.
Das war dann gerade als das klopapier alle war es.
Vor zwei monaten.
Ja
ich finde es ist wahrscheinlich dann auch ein interessantes dokument der zeitgeschichte mal dann zu sehen also ich werde mir glaube ich so wenn wir durch sind werde ich mir dann vielleicht die eine oder andere folge
mal dann wieder anhören und dann kann man mal vergleichen was wir gedacht haben wie es kommen wird und wie es dann gekommen ist
im großen und ganzen habe ich aber das gefühl lagen wir in den meisten dingen die wir so
gesagt oder vorhergesagt haben gar nicht so schlecht oder wie siehst du das.
Ich denke es ist ganz angemessen da jetzt erstmal keine aussage zu machen.
Es bevor man das nicht nach gehört.
Genau.
Ja ja.
Also auf jeden fall am anfang haben wir auch noch einen gewissen humor an einen gewissen schwarzen humor an tag gelegt der da auch am anfang nicht so gut ankam also von daher.
Ja wenn man abschließend kann man vielleicht zum ausland sagen du hattest irgendwann
so eine nette wir bemerkung gemacht die.
Die regierung umso größer die zahlen der länder das scheint sich gerade auch oberflächlich zumindest zu bewahrheiten so brasilien
wo der regierungschef nicht an chorona glaubt der hält das irgendwie für usa.
Frau man glaube ich nicht viel zu sagen die sich ja schon
mit dem brexit so glorreich ausgezeichnet haben performen offenbar in der krise hier jetzt auch nicht gerade wirklich gut
ja russland wie auch immer also es scheint
schon so zu sein dass es sich auch um eine zeit handelt wo es doch gerade mal darauf ankommt dass die regierung nicht zu viel scheiß macht.
Ja und auch sagen wir mal gesundes verhältnis zur wahrheit hat.
Definitiv glaube wahrheit hilft an der stelle oder zumindest zu versuchen eben
so nah wie möglich an die wahrheit vorzudringen bei allen unsicherheiten und schwierigkeiten die man hat aber wenn man sagen selbst den versuch torpediert und
auch einfach mal was auch ganz wichtig ist glaube ich ist geschlossenheit weil sowas auch.
Irgendwie wenn ein drittel oder die hälfte der bevölkerung nicht mitmacht dann kannst du dir auch deine ganzen maßnahmen an die backe schmieren dann kann die andere hälfte irgendwie noch so vorsichtig sein und,
es geht trotz kommt trotzdem nicht zum stillstand da ist es halt auch ganz ganz wichtig sagen nicht zu spät.
Sondern die leute zusammen zu halten und in den usa habe ich gehört wird dann gerne irgendwie werden dann gerne die merkel ansprachen im fernsehen,
und sozusagen mit neid nach deutschland geblickt
wo man ein regierungschef oder eine regierungschefin hat die ja nichts beklopptes von sich gibt.
Die auch in der lage ist in zwei sätzen ärger zu erklären.
Ja genau und ich meine die starke liegt ja sagen gar nicht mal so hoch mittlerweile.
Also ich war bei voraussagen sind also ich glaube das wird auch noch weitergehen also new york könnte sich retten was ich ein bisschen schade finde bei diesen internationalen darstellungen ist
die usa da so als.
Als als als festkörpersysteme betrachtet wird aber man wenn man mal ehrlich ist meine man sieht ja schon wie das in europa sehr unterschiedlich ist,
so und die united states sind nicht so dass man sie nicht mal separat
betrachten sollte und ich würde sehr viel dafür geben dass man jetzt endlich mal anfangen mal kalifornien new york jersey ganzen ost und west küsten starten mal separat zu betrachten von dem was halt in den flyer states stattfindet
texas geht's jetzt auch gerade wild los also das ist das sind alles so ausbruchs herde das sind ja auch unfassbare distanzen die da herrschen das ist ja alles wie europa
bloß noch ein bisschen mehr.
Wer weiß vielleicht auch eine sagen wir vielleicht auch so eine anwendungsfall fürs ranking mal schauen.
Ja wenn man solche zahlen überhaupt bekommt also in usa sieht schlimm aus also ich habe jetzt gerade noch so ein artikel vor die nase bekommen da gab's in florida irgendwie so eine so eine gruppe die extrem transparenten geiles.
Gemacht haben und so und jetzt haben sie einfach mal diese truppe gefeuert weil die irgendwie zu zu wahr berichtet hat so.
Wie kann man denn aus dem lok dorn raus wenn da die ganze zeit leute sagen es wäre alles ganz schlimm und unverantwortlich also das verhältnis zur wahrheit ist glaube ich ein grundlegendes problem der usa und ich habe so ein bisschen den eindruck dass sie dafür noch einen sehr hohen preis.
Bezahlen müssen.
Ja man was man auch sagen muss bisher also es gibt länder da ist es noch schlimmer so
aber nicht viele und nicht viel
das ist natürlich sehr bedauerlich und vor allen dingen ist es natürlich bedauerlich weil die wirtschaftlichen folgen auch für uns
natürlich hilft jetzt nicht mit dem finger auf die usa zu zu zeigen und zu sagen wie schön haben wir es doch hier in europa was auch nicht unbedingt der wahrheit.
Entspricht aber.
Ja die usa muss halt auch die ist ist halt für die weltwirtschaft und auch für unsere wirtschaft einfach eine ganz wichtige.
Extrem wichtig.
Klar und noch ist es in europa auch alles noch schlimmer als in usa also wenn man alle europäischen länder zusammennimmt was eine vergleichbare einwohnerzahl ist dann haben wir hier noch mehr probleme aber ich glaube halt das wird sich ändern also
mein verdacht ist dass e u am ende relativ glimpflich davongekommen wird aber und usa.
Der unterschied ist es bei uns auch sagen die problemlösenden so spanien und italien insbesondere einfach ihre kurve.
Nach unten gekriegt haben spanien besser als italien wie es aussieht.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz so.
Ist das der eigentliche punkt und da kann man jetzt tatsächlich nur hoffen dass irgendwie dann doch die vernünftigen und es ist ja nicht nur so dass der präsident dort.
Dass das alles passiert was der präsident will zum glück nicht sondern da ja da gibt's auch sehr viele vernünftige leute sicherlich sogar in der aktuellen us-regierung
die ist halt gerade eher schwer haben aber es ist nicht.
Die werden schon noch alle gefeuert werden wirst du noch sehen gut lass uns mal jetzt doch zum zweiten teil kommen und mal schauen was
was ich so in digitalen tut.
Die corona warn-app die letzte woche schon ihr erstes lebenszeichen gezeigt hat die
rückt immer näher es gibt jetzt auch eine webseite corona app
wo auf deutsch und auf englisch kurz zusammengefasst wird was sache ist also wo auch
hinweise auf die gitarre quellen sind etcetera relativ technische beschreibung nicht so ganz klar an wen sich das richtet aber hier geht es eher darum die entwickler gemeinde mitzubekommen also ihr wird viel über den ansatz
open source et cetera wenn dann so mit dabei ist
links auf gitarre hatte ich schon erwähnt genau und sie sagen halt auch was passiert wird also demnächst auch einen blog geben und vor allem wenn sie halt weiterhin dinge veröffentlichen.
Übrigens ist das die corona waren seite hat keine trecker und und noch nicht mal cookies.
Nein die gefällt mir heute gerade sagen die gefällt mir eigentlich sehr gut ist sehr schlank
gehalten so und auch das was da drauf steht sozusagen
meistens vielleicht ein bisschen oberkirch so jetzt für die app alleine aber doch also die leute dazu aufzufordern so
eventuell sich ist schuss anzunehmen oder auch die möglichkeit fragen zu stellen aber auch.
Ja report significance security risk also auch offen dazu aufrufen
sicherheitsprobleme zu melden und so
und das ganze sieht also bisher zumindest vom ansatz eigentlich ganz wohltuend aus also wenn das also das könnte ein
beispiel oder ich würde mir würde hoffen dass es ein beispiel sein könnte für weitere.
Staatliches softwareprojekte
so mir gefällt das gut also wenn das demnächst öfter so gemacht wird dann ja dann würde mich das sehr sehr freuen.
Da bin ich ganz
bei dir also es macht auch vor allem den eindruck dass das team dahinter wirklich auch die zeichen der zeit verstanden hat so und am anfang haben wir einige leute auch kräftig die nase gerümpft und hier und sap und telekom was kann denn dabei schon rauskommen aber auch sap ist halt ein unternehmen was schon seit längeren zeit auch open source
projekte macht und so die haben jetzt nicht erst seit gestern präsenz auf geht hab also das.
Da sind teilweise sind die prozesse schon weiter als man denkt beziehungsweise sind natürlich auch solche unternehmen nicht nicht monolithische natürlich gibt's da genug kräfte die in der vergangenheit festkleben wie ist das überall gibt aber sind auch durchaus orte wo neue dinge passieren können und es
das sehen wir hier wahrscheinlich und das
könnte eben durchaus dazu führen wie du schon gesagt hast dass da so eine neue kultur eine chance bekommt also auch in dem letzten op wo ich mit dem oliver droht bogen gesprochen habe war das im prinzip auch so dass ding so das.
Auf einmal so dieses entdecken so ach wie was man kann hier irgendwie schnell agil zu lösungen kommen und dann dann funktioniert das auch und dann kommt da raus die auch benutzbar sind und die so ein
nicht nur neu aussehen und sich anfühlen sondern ja auch in gewisser hinsicht diese ganzen learnings von usability und und und und und und wieso benutzerführung ist also all das was in den letzten zehn zwanzig jahren so schritt für schritt für schritt
entwickelt wurde und langsam in so einem,
mindset der entwickler gemeinden auch einsingen dass das eben jetzt auch einfach zeit ist dass man auszupacken und auszurollen.
Das ist so ein bisschen meine meine meine hoffnung hier müssen wir natürlich mal abwarten was passiert jetzt.
Ist ja auch schon,
dieses system architecture publiziert worden also ich hatte letzte mal war ja nur dieses dokument wie sie sich die app so vorstellen und er hat sich ja abgezeichnet dass eben dieses testing hier auch mit
integriert werden soll jetzt geht es halt noch ein bisschen weiter also es gibt
jetzt hier ein umfängliches dokument was diese ganze struktur des systems nochmal deutlicher beschreibt als das so bisher passiert ist die sogenannte solution.
Ist hier breitgetreten worden und das das ist ganz interessant.
Weil hier jetzt mal wirklich im detail auch die ganze interaktion der einzelnen komponenten aufgezeichnet wird und auch mal ersichtlich ist welche komponenten ist überhaupt gibt.
Übrigens auf geht ab auch da wieder so ein kleines detail ne also alle grafiken sind in s v ganzen dokumente sind im markt dauern und so also das ist alles das fühlt sich alles sehr open source an.
Und beschreibt die sachen ganz gut und es wird immer klarer dass halt auch dieses gitter reporter tory so ein bisschen
ist ne also das das ist sozusagen der ort wo wo wirklich definiert ist wie wie es ist und es sind nicht nur irgendwelche netten lief die man mal dazu produziert hat und irgendwo dahinter entsteht irgendwas,
gas dickes ja vielleicht kann man mal zu dieser struktur was sagen.
Also ganz klar es gibt natürlich die app ja.
Ja schon ein paar mal darauf hingewiesen so das ist immer so diese wahrnehmung wann kommt die app die app die app die app dass die app halt
eigentlich passt das kleinste teil in diesem ganzen system ist das ja nochmal eine andere sache die man verstehen muss und jetzt ist halt auch klar wie dieses projekt.
Strukturiert sein wird denn es gilt ja hier verschiedene quellen anzusprechen und grob gesagt.
Kann man davon sprechen es gibt hier so weiß ich nicht so ganz genau wie ich's zählen soll aber es gibt erstmal ganz grob.
Die app und es gibt.
Das backend also es gibt das was in der cloud läuft und das ist dann halt in dieser open telekom cloud das ist eine infrastruktur von der telekom werden diese anwendung
laufen werde aber von sap programmiert und dieses ganze backend teilt sich tatsächlich so in so
drei große systeme oder wie groß sie sind kann ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen aber die auch so so eine funktionale trennung voneinander haben.
Da gibt's dann erstmal den korona warn-app server der übrigens wo jetzt auch der erste source coach und veröffentlicht wurde,
letzten montag der ist nicht fertig sondern man sieht so ah okay existiert hier struktur ist noch ein bisschen boiler
mit drin also sozusagen
den ich fertig ist und wo noch die details ausgefüllt werden müssen und wo protokolle fehlen et cetera aber wo man schon mal sehen kann okay wie ist das ausgelegt was wir testing gibt es in diesen ganzen sachen ich hatte mal darum gebeten dass leute die sich mit japan gut auskennen mit ja aber.
Entwicklung sich das mal anschauen so würde sagen im schnitt waren so die bemerkung mit so jan nicht fertig aber das ist auch erstmal nichts falsch aus so halbwegs modernes halbwegs moderne herangehensweise an die art und weise wie man das alles
aufbaut und hat jetzt keine geschrien.
Dieser erste teil sehr corona warn-app server also mit dem namen komme ich immer noch nicht klar ja.
Das ist das ist sozusagen der teil der.
Die kies verteilt also wenn jetzt jemand sagt hier ich infiziert und man wird halt gebeten mit jetzt lade mal eine kies der letzten vierzehn tage hoch also diese sogenannten diagnose kies die andere telefone in die lage versetzen das dann eben mit dem zu vergleichen,
was man selber gesehen hat dann kann man halt feststellen aha okay bin ich jetzt ein bisschen zu nahe gekommen und ich bin unter umständen neben jetzt auch dran.
Diese daten bisher von irgendjemand verteilt werden und das ist das was diese erste veröffentlichte oder teil veröffentlichte komponente macht also es ist halt das teil was diese kies annimmt und dann eben der öffentlichkeit,
bereitstellt also konkret wird es dann halt auf so einem content delivery network.
Weil das in den letzten endes nur daten die man nur runterladen muss da muss da nicht sehr viel mehr interaktion stattfinden der punkt ist halt nur man will ja verhindern dass.
Daten jetzt online gestellt werden von leuten die gar nicht getestet wurden also es muss irgendeiner form eine überprüfung geben und der clou ist das halt so eine app in dem moment wo sie.
Kies veröffentlichen möchte muss sie eine tan bekommen so eine transaktionsnummer so quasi so ein freischalte um das zu tun und wenn diese.
App aufm telefon diese tan bekommen hat kann sie also die kies hochladen und dieser kroner warn-app verteilungskurve nimmt dann eben diese tan und sagt so ah hier ich habe gerade kies bekommen.
Stimmt denn das überhaupt und das ist dann eine zweite komponente das ist dieser sogenannte verifiziert server das ist also eine komponente die.
Nur dazu da ist dinge zu überprüfen und die halt auch diese tan ausgibt das heißt bevor man eben diese kies hochlädt muss eben dieses system sich quasi diese erlaubnis holen,
von diesem verifiziert server der stellt sozusagen sicher ja okay diesen test hat's auch.
Tatsächlich gegeben der ist legitim und der darf halt jetzt auch entsprechend hochgeladen werden,
sprich dieser verifiziert server diese zweite bisher noch unveröffentlichte komponente ist dazu da diese anbindung an die eigentlichen testing labs vorzunehmen.
Und so wie ich das verstehe wird hier eine bereits existenz
tieren der infrastruktur der telekom benutzt das heißt die telekom das hatte ich ja auch schon mal erwähnt als das buchbar wurde dass die telekom und sap hier in diesem projekt engagiert sind die telekom hat eben schon so ein
system was an das quasi alle testlabor angeschlossen sind.
Sprich ein testlabor in deutschland ist in der lage diesem laboratory information system diesem zu sagen hier ist ein test.
Das heißt die sind der autorisiert sprich dieses system kann mit den kommunizieren oder
andersrum diese labore können mit diesem system kommunizieren sprich wenn so ein test
vorliegt kann dieser verifiziert server vom c projekt da hingehen und sagen gib mal testergebnis.
Und kann dieses testergebnis der app präsentieren.
Und die app kann dann halt sagen okay war positiv ich habe reingeguckt gibt meine tan und mit dieser tat wird's dann halt durch diesen warn-app server letztlich veröffentlicht.
Ich hab's jetzt mal ganz bewusst mal von hinten aufgezogen weil diese ganze testing geschichte ist ja jetzt eigentlich das interessante und war immer die frage wie läuft denn das eigentlich
das sieht so aus dass wenn man jetzt symptome hat und man landet irgendwie beim gesundheitsamt und die sagen so hier.
Du lässt dich jetzt mal testen komm ich also in diese testing situation da muss ich ja zwangsläufig physikalisch.
Anwesend sein da muss ich ja hingehen so und muss meine daten abgeben und sagen ja okay hier ich werde jetzt getestet tralala und mit
diesen test also mit der proben entnahme erhalte ich bereits eine das heißt dieser test der in dem moment gestartet wird kriegt eine aldi.
Und wird mir präsentiert in form eines barcodes das heißt wenn ich diese app habe zu dem zeitpunkt
nur dann macht es eigentlich auch sinn weil dann habe ich ja auch kies ne also ich habe dann zieht dann einfach mein telefon raus und sagst so aha schöner barcode dann merkt sich quasi mein telefon mein telefon kriegt diese von diesem test.
Und dann nach kann mein telefon also meine app mit diesem verifiziert server reden und sagen ja ich habe hier diese tests bekommen.
Da würde ich ganz gerne mal das ergebnis von haben das heißt du generierst aus dieser idee in so einem nur ein einziges mal
durchführbar vorgang quasi so eine anfrage das heißt du kriegst dann von dem sauber die information so a okay für diesen test hat noch keiner angefragt offensichtlich.
Bist du derjenige der jetzt hier autorisiert ist also die idee ist dann quasi auch das passwort weil die kann man sich irgendwie nicht ausdenken weil es
große große zahl ist und damit bist du dann bei diesem server registriert und dann in der folge check deine app halt regelmäßig und fragt halt immer wieder nach.
Hör mal hier da ist noch ein test auf den hass und ergebnis verify server guckt bei diesem laptop nach und sagt so ja nee ist noch nichts da probiere später nochmal und und so weiter interessanterweise kommen hier keine push-notification zum einsatz.
Auch wieder so einen punkt hier wurde ganz bewusst darauf verzichtet
überhaupt irgendwelche informationen über diese app auf dem telefon zu speichern finde ich echt gut weil an der stelle hätte man
sagen können ja hier push-notification so macht man das heutzutage und dann hättest du dann doch halt wieder so ein party dienst in dem fall halt notification server wo du so eine anfrage machst du her hier ist jemand der hat wohl ein test so weißt du denn dann dann.
Legst du quasi schon wieder so eine datenspuren aus und das soll halt vermieden werden das kannst du halt dadurch vermeiden indem man einfach ganz konsequent auf so einem puls.
Systems und setzt und die müssen halt selber fragen weil die haben ja diesen token sie haben sozusagen diese anfrage einmal generiert und damit
quasi die erlaubnis nach dem ergebnis dieses tests zu fragen.
Dann ist der test vielleicht tatsächlich durch und auch in diesem labor informationssystem vermerkt
dann kommt die app nochmal sagt was ist denn jetzt mit meinem test der sauber guck nach der sagt ja okay ergebnis ist da hier ergebnis wobei der verifiziert aber in dem moment der weiß dann sozusagen auch das ergebnis.
Teilt das dieser app mit und dann steht da drin okay du bist positiv.
Dann kann die app sagen okay alles klar wie ist es willst du jetzt hier mal deine kies scheren weil das ist ja der sinn dieser ganzen geschichte dass wir jetzt andere warnen kann sondern dass sie ja okay meinetwegen dann schicke ich halt meine blöden kissen die wolke
und dann geht die app halt wieder zu diesem verifiziert server der ja weiß dass dein test positiv war sagt ok ich will ihn jetzt auch veröffentlichen gib mal die tan und das ist dann sozusagen diese freischaltung für den schritt den ich vorhin schon beschrieben habe dass die daten dann eben auch rausgehen
ja das ist eigentlich ein ganz interessantes und wie ich finde auch elegantes system also mir würde jetzt zumindest nicht einfallen.
Wie man das groß hätte anders machen sollen und das ist auch nicht unnötig komplex und es ist auch vergleichsweise einfach zu verstehen
jetzt habe ich zwei komponenten dieses backens beschrieben es gibt noch ein drittes das ist der sogenannte portal server unser portal server ist
quasi nochmal so ein extra jusos front end für diesen verifizierung server wozu braucht man den.
Jetzt gibt es viele konstellationen wo man sich vorstellen kann dass irgendwas davon schiefgeht du hast die nicht richtig eingescannt oder dein telefon hat irgendwas,
hat nicht funktioniert oder irgendwas oder du bist dazu nicht in der lage oder du hast es vergessen et cetera also wird immer wieder diese fälle geben wo du unter umständen dann doch nochmal mit echten menschen in verbindung.
Musst und die gesundheitsämtern haben halt über diesen portal server zugriff auf dieses verifizierung system das heißt
können halt tests auch bestätigen die können halt sagen genauso wie dieses labor informationssystem so ja okay das dieser test hat jetzt wirklich stattgefunden und die leute können halt auch bei so einer hotline anrufen und sich dort auch nochmal so eine sogenannte
teletext geben lassen mit der man eben diese anfrage nach dem test auch nochmal generieren kann wenn man die all die nicht gecheckt hat also das sind so verschiedene mechanismen schon vorgesehen die auch
konsequent so vom news cases her abbilden und ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen dass das so auch ganz gut funktionieren kann.
Mit einer worten
da tut sich jetzt was es wird an drei system gebaut alle drei sind am ende wichtig am wichtigsten ist natürlich dieses verteilt teil und dieser verifizierung
teil und die telekom wird sicherlich auch noch an dem ein oder anderen zu basteln haben um dann diese kommunikation nach außen dieses verifizierung system herzustellen wird man sehen wie lange das jetzt dauert ich habe gehört.
Dreizehn fünf wo jetzt dieses dieser neue api diese exporter notification abi drin es ist jetzt fertig
es gibt da so eine golden master das wird also jetzt wahrscheinlich in den nächsten tagen das licht der welt erblicken ich vermute mal wir werden nächste woche.
Das schon auf dem telefon haben weil sie aber nicht hundertprozentig aber danach sieht es aus also auf den iphones zumindest bei google weiß ich nicht ganz genau wie es aussieht.
Und dann könnte man einen release dieser app auch schon näher kommen.
Das dauert wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen also ich würde mich mal so auf ende dieses monats einstellen und ich glaube das ist auch das was
so angekündigt wurde zurecht zuletzt.
Ja was ich noch nicht ganz verstehe so was ich mir vielleicht mal wenn ich zeit habe irgendwann angucken werde ist.
Inwieweit ist das system denn in der lage sagen meine.
Meine exposés also meine ja.
Mein datensatz welche token ich gesehen beziehungsweise ausgesendet habe war dass sich die dich ausgesendet habe genau.
Dass ich dass die sozusagen getrennt dass die mir nicht persönlich zuzuordnen sind weißt du das ob das.
Die sind ja nicht zuzuordnen weil du also deine app lädt diese kies diesem verteilt server diesen c diesen corona warn-app server hoch,
der hat keinerlei kenntnisse über diesen test vorgang deswegen ist das nochmal getrennt mit diesem verifiziert server und,
kommunikation verläuft ausschließlich über die tat das heißt der der verifiziert aber derjenige sieht den test und das ergebnis vermittelt das an die app.
Erhält aber von der app keine daten die app rennen sich an den anderen server und sagt.
Hier ich bin positiv getestet worden und der beweis ist diese tan die hier noch dabei liegt die habe ich vom verifiziert server dann guck dieser warn-app server
beim catering aber vorbei sagt hier hör mal hier ist eine app die sagt die hat ja diagnose kies und hat eine tan von dir stimmt titan.
Guck der kurzen seine datenbank sagt ja klar die tan hab ich vorhin rausgegeben die ist okay also kannst du kannst du machen und dann ist es raus und in diesen dies die veröffentlicht werden.
Steht nichts über dich drin das sind nur crypto kies die irgendwelche von irgendeinem telefon sein können da ist keinerlei bezug zu dir.
Ja ja ich meine grundsätzlich gilt natürlich erstmal.
Ja es ist alles erstmal aufgeteilt in verschiedene server ok aber für mich als benutzer ist es ganze ein system ja.
So und dieses eine system gibt mir halt eine tanne raus und es ist überprüft.
Auch die tante das heißt da ich,
sagen da ist die frage welche kryptografisch methoden dort genutzt werden
um zu verhindern dass wenn ich halt zugriff auf alle daten habe dieser verschiedenen
server wenn ich die halt alle zusammen schmeiße die daten so ist es dann immer noch sicher oder ist es dann möglich.
Es werden ja keine anderen daten veröffentlicht außer deiner kies ist.
Es fallen einfach ist fallen einfach keine daten an die veröffentlicht werden können wenn du jetzt sagst da ja aber man kann mir das ja zuordnen dann redest du von einem wissen was ohnehin schon vorliegt das liegt beim gesundheitsamt da liegt das testergebnis mit adresse.
Ja dass er ja das ja ja das liegt das liegt alles vor als liegt alles beim gesundheitsamt vor bis auf sagen meine.
Exporter daten so ja bis auf die sozusagen bieten daten.
Ja aber die die kommen halt ins gesundheitsamt auch nicht wieder zurück.
Ja aber die nur so sagen da ist mir noch nicht ganz klar.
Wie die crypto da aussieht ich hatte ich habe mir das auch noch nicht im im detail angeguckt da ist von diversen verschiedenen hasches die rede die da eingeführt werden aber natürlich.
Mir ist halt noch nicht ganz klar wie es hinkriegst wenn du selbst wenn du irgendeine information hashtag.
Und du hast aber die kennt sie ausgangsdateien die geherrscht
wurden dann kannst du halt das alles auch aufdecken so so das ist ja ich.
Ich sage nur dass es definitiv also das ist wäre für mich der punkt,
sagen an der architektur den ich mir vielleicht nochmal.
Dir anschauen ich meine das ding ist immer nur an welche informationen würde man denn überhaupt noch herankommen wollen die man so nicht sowieso hat so veröffentlicht werden keine gesundheitsdaten die verbleiben beim gesundheitsamt das ist aber sind aber daten die die hat der staat
weil das eine fucking meldepflichtig krankheit die daten sind eh da
frage die sich jetzt in in diesem hinzufügen dieser app stellt ist liefert diese app irgendwelche daten die ich nicht veröffentlicht haben möchte und das einzige was sie veröffentlicht sind diese.
Kies von vierzehn tagen aus dem man die aldis rausfinden kann die werden alle auch unzusammenhängende veröffentlicht das heißt am ende sind diese vierzehn tage die du veröffentlichst können.
Sowohl als vierzehn tage von einer person angesehen werden sind aber technisch überhaupt nicht auseinander zu halten das heißt es ist quasi so als hätten vierzehn leute einen tag
gemeldet und es steht auch explizit nochmal in der doku drin dass man sogar darüber nachdenkt dann explizit die nochmal alphabetisch zu sortieren also lexikon grafisch zu sortieren damit die keinerlei zusammenhang haben das heißt selbst wenn du
die kies runterlädst dann dann kriegst du irgendwelche kies in irgendeiner reihenfolge die nichts darüber aussagen was dazu was gehört und die telefone selber die dann eben mit diesem kissen vergleich machen.
Die sehen halt auch nur irgendjemand war in deiner nähe an diesem tag das ist die einzige information die du bekommst auf basis der genannten
kriterien.
Mein punkt.
Ist dass ich das gefühl habe oder das bisher überprüft zu haben dass es aber zwingend erforderlich ist dass der ganze kram open source ist und auch so betrieben
wird wie vorgesehen und dass es sehr wohl möglich wäre meiner meinung nach
sagen als server,
ja schon eine zuordnung vorzunehmen wenn das nicht explizit ausgeschlossen und und erschwert.
Aber zu hat.
Was ich meine es ist.
Ja natürlich es gibt.
Ich kriege eine tante vom system und
wenn ich meine daten hochlade muss ich die tante mitschicken also ist das system theoretisch erstmal in der lage sagen meine tanne mir und den daten zuzuordnen ja verstehst du was ich meine.
Ja es stimmt.
Ja so wenn ich jetzt das heißt es ist schon ich habe schon das gefühl dass es wichtig ist dass der ganze kram open source und es ist auch sichergestellt ist dass das was dann
als open source version öffentlich bekannt ist dass es auch dasselbe ist was dann da läuft an software.
Klar also.
All diese komponenten also mit der aufnahme ausnahme dieses labor informationssystems was aber ja nur so ein proxy ist zwischen den laboren und diesem verifiziert server das ist halt eine puppe verlosung vom von der telekom das.
Spielt aber an der stelle auch keine rolle weil die eigentlich nur die daten nur durchleitet.
Das finde ich auch okay das hat damit habe ich also mit den dingern habe ich habe ich echt kein problem.
Alle anderen komponenten sind sind open source und am ende wird halt keinerlei zuordnung veröffentlicht deswegen bin ich da auch so entspannt also
klar könnten sie theoretisch dass da irgendwie machen aber sie werden ja nicht veröffentlicht also diese daten werden nicht angeboten und nicht runtergeladen und es gibt auch nichts was auswerten könnte also.
Genau will nur sagen wenn es so.
Umgesetzt wird und so läuft wie das da spezifiziert ist habe ich da auch keine probleme ich bin interessiert nur ob sie eine möglichkeit vielleicht gefunden haben und sagen dass auch das system,
wenn es wollte sagen oder wenn wenn jemand wollte
also ja irgendwie inwieweit muss ich dem den betrieb und der betriebsunterbrechung vertrauen und inwieweit ist das durch.
Das protokoll durch das kommunikationsprozess voll und die kryptografisch methoden möglicherweise sichergestellt dass keine zuordnung möglich ist und da bin ich stecke ich noch nicht tief genug drin.
Da waren wir da sicherlich auch in den nächsten tagen und wochen noch mehr erfahren wenn dann halt dieser source auch draußen ist weil gerade dieser verifiziert sauber und die von dir angesprochene tante der ist halt jetzt noch nicht sichtbar aber das werden wir dann alles sehen,
jetzt wollte ich nochmal auf eine andere sache kommen.
Und zwar die frage des wie ich das immer so schön nenne des roaming weil es ein begriff ist den jeder kennt denn letztlich.
Reden wir hier über eine lösung für deutschland und das grundproblem ist natürlich
ja okay deutschland alles schön und gut aber ich will ja jetzt auch nicht immer in deutschland bleiben und sollte so ein system uns nicht auch in irgendeiner form ein schutz geben können oder eine eine hilfestellung sein wenn wir deutschland verlassen und was ist denn dann eigentlich
los.
Da gibt's jetzt im prinzip zwei probleme das eine haben wir hier schon öfter diskutiert nämlich das problem andere länder sind noch nicht bereit sich auf dieses dezentralisierte modell einzulassen.
Meine these ist die vergeuden nur ihre zeit und die werden am ende umknicken das gilt
speziell für frankreich und gibt auch noch ein paar andere pappenheimer aber ich glaube der druck aus den anderen ländern wird am ende siegen aber das ist nur meine persönliche these
das heißt wir laufen eigentlich auf eine welt zu in der wir davon ausgehen können dass wir grundsätzlich kompatibles mit
verwenden in europa.
Ich denke auch der druck der eu wird am ende da einfach dafür sorgen dass das auch frankreich klein beigeben muss aber wenn man mal sehen ich glaube die werden zumindest hart kämpfen.
Jetzt ist aber natürlich noch das andere problem ja wie machen wir denn das jetzt technisch weil wenn wir eine infrastruktur haben die nur in deutschland läuft was ist denn dann.
Mit italien italien hat gesagt wir setzen auf das gleiche system sowie deutschland jetzt gerade diese open source entwicklung auch vorantreibt.
Werde ich noch nicht mal überrascht wenn wir diese corona warn-app relativ schnell auch in anderen ländern sehen die einfach kein bock oder kein,
keine kapazität haben diesen ganzen stress selber zu machen da muss man dann immer noch diese anbindung an die labor geschichte anpassen aber das ist dann halt fällt gleich weise wenig weil dann eben achtzig prozent oder neunzig prozent der arbeit schon
gelöst ist das ist alles.
Unter einer korrekten dezenz veröffentlicht also überhaupt gar kein problem das zu verwenden also wer wird das wahrscheinlich auch passieren das heißt wir haben kompatibles system aber was passiert jetzt ich fahre jetzt nach italien.
Lauf da rum und dann sind halt viele italienische telefone um mich herum so da fahre ich wieder nach hause und dann bin ich irgendwie krank und dann.
Schicke ich meine kies in die deutschland wolke und alle deutschen telefone laden sich das runter und sagen wir noch nie gesehen.
Weil ich habe ja da nur mein virus in italien verbreitet den italienischen telefone wiederum.
Haben auch nichts gesehen weil was haben die mit deutschen server zu tun die kriegen das von ihrem italienischen server und sehen das halt alles nicht,
und das ist halt absurd weil dieses thema ja kompatibel zueinander sind sie verwenden dieselbe kryptografisch methode dasselbe bluetooth protokoll alles ist dasselbe da läuft überall derselbe code und.
Die schicken sich bloß ihre kies nicht das ist das problem.
Und jetzt gibt es von der also diese gruppe die dieses dezentralisierte projekt ja extrem vorangetrieben hat und wo sich auch
apple am anfang hat von inspirieren lassen oder vielleicht auch immer noch inspirieren lässt
und haben jetzt eine eine spezifikation veröffentlicht die den klangvollen namen dies sind city tracing interoperabel spezifikation trägt
also kurz gesagt wir versuchen hier eine interoperabel zwischen den ländern herzustellen und ich muss sagen dieses dokument lässt mir ein paar sorgen falten ins gesicht ziehen
nicht weil ich jetzt hier irgendwie entdeckt hätte dass er große security probleme entstehen oder neue datenschutzaktivist aufkommen die das alles nicht daran ändert sich ja dadurch eben nix
sondern weil ich mir einfach fragen wie das bitte funktionieren soll kurz gesagt ihre idee ist folgender.
Also so steht es in diesem dokument vielleicht noch eine andere und sie haben es nicht richtig aufgeschrieben aber für mich macht das nur begrenzt sind die idee ist dass wenn ich mein diagnose abgebe dass ich dann zu dem zeitpunkt sage.
Okay ich bin also jetzt hier gemeldet hier habt ihr meine kies ach ja übrigens ich war in italien.
Und dann nimmt halt die dieses backend diese kies entgegen und sagt so ach illegalisieren war so na super dann schicken wir die auch mal nach italien
und dann wird das halt alles in italien ausgegossen und alle italienischen telefone kriegen halt mein kiel also was wie hier deutscher irgendwie ich bin krank zack.
Test und so weiter so würde das funktionieren keine frage genauso in die andere richtung wenn die italiener nach deutschland kommen.
Sofern sie halt beim absenden auch dran denken zu sagen dass sie in dem land waren ich sage mal ganz frech.
Weißt du immer welchem land du warst also das ist ja in europa so eine sache ja also fahr mal so benelux
grenzgebiet durch die gegend okay gut also vielleicht kann man das noch klarmachen aber es es gibt schon sehr schwammige bereiche in in europa.
Also bei mir persönlich ich glaube ich würde das normalerweise schon zusammenkriegen für die letzten vierzehn tage in welchen ländern ich mich
aufgehalten habe aber ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass es leute gibt die so viel unterwegs
sind dass das tatsächlich nicht ganz einfach ist also stichwort keine ahnung fernfahrer oder wenn du in bestimmten ja gut bei grenznahen regionen ok da weißt du.
Ja oder dein umsteige flughafen den übersehen hast so bis.
Gefühlt von danach da geflogen aber du bist ja dann auch noch in holland umgestiegen und so also man kann sowas vergessen und vor allem das problem ist du musst dran denken also da,
gibt hier keine automatik
und die will man ja eigentlich auch nicht haben weil das ganze system soll ja die eigene location nicht,
so dass man das automatisch ranbauen könnte was ja im prinzip ganz einfach wäre aber datenschutz privatsphäre etcetera alles alles klar
so warum habe ich jetzt an diesem system eigentlich mit diesem system problem das ist halt das konferenz problem so würde ich das jetzt mal nennen.
Weil klar kann ich mal nach italien fahren und treffe italiener und italiener können nach deutschland fahren und treffen viele deutsche aber wenn ich jetzt auf eine konferenz fahre.
Die in frankreich ist und ich treffe da meine italiener.
Und ich sage dann ja ok ich war in frankreich und dann werden meine kies zwar nach frankreich ausgespielt aber nicht nach italien.
Nichts gewonnen also das und das das sehe ich in diesem protokoll überhaupt nicht drin also diese absurde vorstellung man müsse jetzt als user sagen wo man war und dann werden diese länder beschickt aber wenn ich
leute getroffen haben die gar nicht aus dem land sind bringt es alles gar nichts ist.
Genau ich muss eigentlich muss ich zusätzlich.
Du musst es an alle schicken.
Ja nicht nur das ich muss auch zusätzlich eigentlich der app ständig mitteilen in welchen ländern ich mich aufgehalten,
habe nicht nur wenn ich infiziert bin sondern auch wenn ich meine warnungen erhalten möchte um dieses konferenz problem zu lösen das heißt ich müsste halt eigentlich.
Der app dann auch der der warn-app sagen ich bin jetzt in frankreich und dann merkt sich die app das und dann fragt die halt vierzehn tage lang auch in frankreich nach.
Daten.
Okay das würde halt voraussetzen dass meine app auch in der lage ist all die ganzen download server der anderen apps zu befragen.
Vielleicht ist das so gemeint ja also das,
das geht mir derzeit aus dieser spezifikation noch nicht so richtig hervor aber es dann natürlich dann wieder die nächste unsicherheit dass ich dann eben auch das auch noch wieder richtig berücksichtigen muss
und das kann halt leicht sein aber das kann man halt auch irgendwie durcheinander kriegen und ich weiß nicht so richtig ob das
der richtige ansatz ist alternativ müsste man halt alle kies an alle zu stellen.
Wer wahrscheinlich sogar technisch.
Sogar möglich aber würde natürlich schon also es ist natürlich nicht so richtig effizient
also einfacher wäre es wenn die app selber merken.
Würde wobei das auch nicht ganz ganz ohne ist weil gerade ja wenn du in wenn man mit dem auto
zum beispiel bestimmte in bestimmten gegenden wo verschiedene grenzen aufeinander treffen langfährt kriegt man halt schon mit dass man plötzlich dann in drei oder vier ländern auf einmal
eingebucht war so.
Herzlich willkommen in frankreich ihre tarife sind herzlich willkommen in der schweiz ihre tarife sind herzlich willkommen in deutschland ja dieses dreiländereck problem also.
Da beginnt auf jeden fall jetzt dieses diskussion ich würde das jetzt auch nicht zu detailliert ausführen vielleicht geht es halt aber es es geht sozusagen davon aus dass man irgendwie auch die daten von anderen
ländern bekommen kann irgendwo steht in der respekt auch oder war das auf twitter das weiß jetzt gerade nicht mehr ganz genau muss ich nochmal nachgucken dass das dass man doch ich glaube es steht sogar in die seite dieser aspekt mit drin man könnte ja dann auch noch die apps von anderen ländern installieren.
Das ist natürlich irgendwie totaler.
Quatsch ist weil dann hast du meistens solche app store begrenzung und du kannst nicht einfach die von anderen ländern runterladen und so weiter also da
dann ist hier eine anderen sprache dann kannst du nicht benutzen alles wieder anders also das will man ja nicht man will eigentlich nur eine einzige app haben.
Eigentlich aber das hat apple ja glaube ich sogar explizit.
Dicht gemacht oder du darfst halt irgendwie keine location daten sie app darf selber.
Keine location daten fragen und das ist natürlich ein problem das ist eigentlich ein.
Ein grund doch 'ne app aus frankreich runterzuladen ist natürlich der daran habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht gedacht wenn ich jetzt mal ein paar wochen in frankreich bin.
Ich werde dort getestet weil dort passiert was und ich werde dort
und wird dort getestet dann muss ich ja quasi mit diesem lab in frankreich sprechen also das
ganze schreit einfach nach internationalisierung und mindestens einer standardisierung auf europäischer ebene also wenn da jetzt noch weiterhin so viel
jeder seine eigene lösung macht und meine so ein land wie luxemburg was was was was sollen die denn da ja das ist es.
Der wohnt ja keiner der da arbeitet arbeitet ja keiner da wohnt und,
das ist so aufgelöst das ist das ist einfach alles so paaren europäisch und luxemburg ist das eine extrem lichtenstein österreich alle grenzen benelux überhaupt so.
Da geht das eine das andere über und irgendwo wäre es halt besser man hätte halt einfach mal die euro-yappy
die euro korona warn-app ja die du dann eben leicht lokalisieren kannst und sagen kannst ja ich.
Will jetzt aber hier ein test in diesem land durchführen bitte mal da mit dem entsprechenden laptop kommunizieren am ende sind die daten alle die gleichen
also das könnte nochmal eine interessante
interessantes lehrstück für einen zwang zu einer europäisierung in in in rekordzeit sein also will welches gar nicht so überrascht,
wenn wir hier so in zwei drei monaten uns nochmal das anschauen dass wir auf einmal eine wilde diskussion auf europäischer ebene bekommen
wie man das ganze jetzt verallgemeinert und am ende hast du einfach so eine eu korona warn-app und alles ein code und ein team was das mental und das funktioniert für alle gleich.
Und wahrscheinlich könnte die app sogar und das.
Könnte würde apple wahrscheinlich sogar auch zulassen die könnte einfach so ein länder
befragen zum beispiel so sagen ein server der dir sagt in welchem land du dich gerade befindest anhand deiner ip-adresse mit der doris war kommst.
Warum sollte das jetzt machen.
Nein nein nein sozusagen apple nicht verhindern.
Was was genau nicht verhindern.
Sozusagen dann doch die information zu speichern in welchem land du dich befindest so die zu ermitteln auf andere art und weise als über das location framework.
Ja aber es ist es ist ja nicht erforderlich wenn du einfach allen alle kiesbett bereitstellt.
Ja aber das skaliert halt club nicht ganz so gut also vor allem global nicht aber ja grundsätzlich dass wir auf auf jeden fall.
Wahrscheinlich auf europäischer ebene kann man wahrscheinlich sogar allen alle kies zur verfügung stellen aber global schwierig.
Muss man sehen.
Ja das war's jetzt eigentlich so aus diesem bereich ich werde es mal weiter verfolgen ich habe das das dokument ist.
Gestern am montag rausgekommen und wie das immer so ist mit work and progress das wird sich sicherlich bald noch so ein bisschen klären also so ganz so.
Vorwort schreibt mir das an der stelle noch nicht zu sein.
Das system architecture sieht auch so ein bisschen ja ja noch so ein bisschen sehr einfach.
Gut pavel damit sind wir glaube ich am ende dieser sendung.
Ja wie lange ist es denn geworden die ist.
Ja wir sind dann doch wieder auf zwei stunden gekommen aber so ist das halt.
Ich denke du wirst normal nachdenken wie du das mit der ganzen datenveröffentlichung besser hinkriegt und an deiner tabelle schrauben wir freuen uns weiterhin über.
Fehlerkorrekturen kommentare alles mögliche erzählt weiter dass wir hier am analysieren sind ja und wasser erst mal für diese woche oder.
Und ich denke nächste woche wird es noch nicht vorbei sein ich glaube eine mindestens eine sendung.
Da kriegen wir noch hin.
Kriegen wir noch hin eine haben wir noch eine hammer noch.
Ich glaube das trägt noch ein bisschen schauen wir mal okay alles klar tschüss.
Ok tschüss.
Bald und nächste woche hier wieder bei.